wave to chrissy
representative bartlett is here in
in spirit and uh
i assume
she has one of yours uh
email or text number so she can text you
guys
okay
so
i think this is going to be fairly
straightforward and all the morning
bills were pretty pretty straightforward
um
and
and then we just have and i have some
new insights now on some of these later
bills so
okay so this is insurance
and do i know who who's on the insurance
subcommittee
i don't i think john dwight do we
actually have the subcommittee
notions okay how many forms do you have
there
hopefully one for each bill but okay
cool okay so that should be double we
should have the members on it
yeah yeah you know
i don't have
so
you know what that's this i'm not gonna
worry about it
i think everything i think these are
gonna be straightforward right
okay so actually i need my pile so uh
okay
so first one's up 354 and we do have an
amendment for it
so
anybody who cares does it get a have a
copy of the amendment
so where where you have them where you
have them right now they're
was that was that the order to it
yeah so this one this one uh
oh it got it got really uh well it's
hard to tell what was the original bill
right okay
i'm gonna take off my green man
jacket
because i can't wear it till sunday
right
i do have my masters tie
okay
and i assume the department has got a
copy
oh
so you have a copy of those amendments
[Music]
three fifty four
no i have two or four and i have two of
these
two four two six three fifty four six
two four so there's just the three right
just three pages three papers okay
okay
so
where was the where was the word change
i think it was
it was line six
his line it said per violation or any
combination or actions and i believe it
was changed to of
actions yes
okay there it
is right
there
yeah okay otherwise it looks good
any combinations
okay so who's normally on the insurance
okay
good
aren't you you're on the insurance yeah
you too
okay
and then we have anita and then
and someone's replaced christy is not
here so i'm subbing
okay yeah all right so that's that's
fine
okay so we have
okay i'm glad you're here
okay
so
fargo
and burroughs
okay
all right so who would like to carry
this forward i think it's going to go on
the consent calendar who would like to
make the uh pass
um can i speak to something before we
make the recommendation
on behalf of connie's concerns okay i
we spoke a little bit about this
yesterday but she was concerned with
roman numeral 12
failing to comply with an administrative
or court order imposing child support
obligation okay she felt that it would
be covered in roman numeral eight
um
using fraudulent course over dishonest
practices but i think we had a
conversation john that maybe we just
want to
speak to again about why this was um
singled out individually and what the
impact would be so there's a clear
understanding well my comment was that
as an employer
i learned one day that that the last
thing an employer wants to see is this
pink sheet from the irs
and that the infamous pink sheet means
that you have to that that actually i
don't have to do anything there the irs
is just going to come and take the money
out of my our corp our check account the
business account they're just going to
sweep it right out of the account
and and pay
for somebody who has not been doing
their child support payments so i'm
assuming that that's where this comes
from but did did you guys do any
follow-up on this
the insurance department did you guys
look at this at all or
that question that came up yesterday
excuse me while we're waiting are we
just jumping all over from build i'm not
sure where we are here i i
threw my head are we back to 354 from
206. this is 300 354. 354. the first so
so now we're going okay so we we were on
206. we were for a moment we were never
on well
is the of in 354 yes yeah
we were on the wrong one all right so
we're on 354. thank you very much it's
good to know what county i'm in as well
as state
merrimack
yeah yeah yeah that's 354.
right okay hi
yeah you have to push the button so
chrissy can hear you good morning again
my name is joshua hillard i'm the
compliance and enforcement council of
new hampshire insurance department
and to address your question not only is
it reflective of 402j which has that
same language as to child support orders
as to insurance producers i understand
through conversation that there was a
concerted effort about 20 or 30 years
ago to make it that a lot of the
professional license in the state could
be impacted by not um being current with
child support so my understanding is
that's consistent across a number of the
professional licenses in the state
okay
representative greeson
thank you mr chair i i see this the bill
is dealing with licensed denial
non-renewal or revocation and there
needs to be a good cause for doing so to
either deny a license to not renew a
license or to revoke a license
and
good cause is being defined as we're
including this the several listed items
and failing to comply with an order to
impose
to pay child support shows a lack of
integrity in fulfilling one's financial
obligations and if you lack integrity in
in paying your financial obligations
then you are not going to be
responsible in other decisions
potentially
as it relates to your profession and
therefore a license uh
would it be reasonable to assume if
you're not responsible in that area and
fail to comply with those orders you're
probably likely to not comply with other
orders
that's how i read it okay but what are
we still on the right bill number let's
see
so this was
that that
line that she was looking at yeah where
what bill was that is on the sheet
we have the right bill
that was the amendment to 354 that just
changed
okay so she's looking at the underlying
bill and this was the amendment okay
yeah the amount i thought we agreed the
amendment was fine it was just a change
of the underlying bill okay right this
is the underlying bill thank god okay mr
chairman thank you for
helping me to realize i wasn't the only
one who was confused confused i can be
confused well if you're confused it
makes everything all right now
okay i have a question yes
would it be appropriate yes please sir
thank you uh
so
following on representative greeson's
question with respect to good cause um
i'm i'm concerned
with uh the phrase but is not limited to
so you have 12 items here
which are
reference points or measurements for
good cause
what are
the other good causes
are they enumerated anywhere or
is this merely a a judgment call on the
first on the part of the person making
the judgment
thank you
thank you that's a good question so to
to answer that
this bill was an effort to try to
enumerate that if you notice the statute
as it reads now does not define good
cause
so this provides those 12 enumerated
definitions which are mirrored in that
in 402j which is those reasons for which
we may bring an action against an
insurance producer an insurance agent
this is an insurance adjuster
but as you identified the not limited to
language indicates there of course could
be other scenarios that might not fit
neatly into one of these 12
under which the department would wish to
bring an action against an insurance
adjuster
for conduct that would suggest they
should not be licensed and operating in
the state
follow
in which case if if that were the case
that there were other
cause
causes
they would need to be identified and
defended
but other than that which is in the
statute
so this the statute if if it's enacted
makes it firm all you'd have to do is
refer
to one or more of these causes if in
fact you were bringing an action under
one or more of those causes if it's a
cause or causes not
i uh that has been added
if it to this to this law
then your burden would be a little
higher would you agree
if i understand your your question
appropriately if the compliance
enforcement council to convince the
hearing officer that if it fell outside
of that 12 that this still rose to
good cause to bring action correct great
thank you
once like spell it out for me and spell
it out but then the other day if they
contest it they're going to go
yes
if adopted these 12 items move the ball
way down the field because what i heard
in testimony is that there were no 12
items before just a good cause
this this gives a foundation
but there may it has indicated in the in
the uh on line nine there may be other
causes
but this is a vast improvement over the
fact that there was nothing before
excellent okay thank you representative
terry
seconded by representative greeson
my reward that's my reward
uh moves uh ought to pass on the
amendment is there any discussion on the
amendment see none all those in favor
please raise your hand
one two three four five okay
and that amendment number is one three
four six h okay
all right
uh then uh octopass has amended
representation second by representative
greeson
okay uh discussion um uh representation
ii by representing greece and moves out
to pass as amended do you
want to discuss it anymore or are we all
we're okay are we okay
all right all those in favor of octopus
as amended please raise your hand
three four five
and we're done so mr chair just real
quick uh since uh
is not here
is she satisfied with our answer yes yes
right otherwise we know that she would
be texting us until he is she's not
happy right
okay so next up is
okay is senate bill 204 relative the
definition of covered claim for the
purpose
of the new hampshire insurance
guaranteed association act
all right
okay so the latest amendment is 1347 h
okay
and
what was what was this amendment
okay so what are we trying to do in this
amendment what are we trying to do here
it appears as though the word
non-member have been dropped out under
number two so it merely states the
insurer
okay
sure
the member's cover is on that's one
change
okay
all right so you guys are okay with this
amendment then
you have demons yes good morning uh many
members i'm heather silverstein general
counsel of the insurance department uh
yes we reviewed this yesterday and um
this is the language that we would
recommended to the bill
um the guarantees association had
actually proposed making this little
tweak for the amendment and we agreed
with it just to further clarify
um
that if you're a
member when the policy is issued then it
then even if that policy gets consumed
by another company
um it would still be covered later even
if that company insurance company was
not a member
okay so with respect to the change
what was in the original was non-member
insurer
uh i don't recall that we
identified the issue was this something
that you all
looked at again and decided that you
wanted changed
or did we provide any wisdom on this for
you no this was no we had suggested the
amendment yeah he did yes
let's say that after second reading from
after it left the senate and before it
got here
in between yes okay
this is why it's great having a bi-camry
legislation yes we have multiple bites
at the apple you might want to remind
the senate of that
mr
chairman the people on the other side of
the wall inside
the other side
thank you
that's right
okay who would
you like to carry this one for you want
to carry this one forward jeff oh no no
you're sure
fine representative hunt seconded by
representative terry
uh moose ought to pass
on the amendment the amendment number
being 1347 13
47.
any discussion on the amendment
saying none all those in favor please
raise your hand 1 2 3 4 5.
okay
um representative hunt
making my
representative
moves
out to pass as amended
any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor raise
your hand one two three four five
and so moved okay
uh
oh okay
all right next up
all right how are we doing with 205
any amendments for this one or
you all set with
205 okay
anybody want to make the motion
all right thank you remember
okay fargo
second by representative hunt
moves
ought to pass
any discussion on the motion about to
pass
see none all those in favor raise your
hand let's suppose
zip
okay
oh
all right 206 we have an amendment
all right you guys had a chance to look
over this amendment
okay this is number
1349.
we'd like to make the motion
okay
my sponsor
i am
okay thank you
okay representative
fargo second by representative hunt
moves out to pass on the amendment
number 1349 is there any discussion on
the motion scene on the clerk we'll call
no they'll be okay
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed
move hi
yeah okay
all right now representative fargo
second by representative hunt
moves uh uh to pass as amended
any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor raise
your hand
cause opposed
okay
next up
as introduced
okay
no problem okay so 207 there's no need
amendment right speak now or forevermore
hold your peace
okay
who would like to make the motion
thank you remember that
okay representative fargo second by
representative hunt moves out to pass
any discussion on the motion see none
all those in favor raise your hand one
two three four five
okay
[Music]
amendments on 208
what a marvel
for a rewrite right this is a big
rewrite
cool
all right
we like to carry this forward
am i a sponsor of this too
no
you can do it when we get when we get to
uh you know the exec session all right
all right
so the to the matrix
yeah no i i do have it but i mean that's
just like an index to help you find
things
okay uh so
representative hunt
seconded by representative fargo
moves ought to pass
any discussion on the motion
t none all those in favor raise your
hand
so we have this is hunt
uh
and
greason
and terry
and
oh parker
right
okay next up is
285 is that correct
i do have a question about this one okay
let me just uh sort my papers here so
okay
oh
relative to discount medical plan
organizations
okay did you say you had a common
question on that one um yes i do i
um
i was wondering if the subcommittee
would be open to having a discussion
about um line 19
one of the requirements is of good
character which i find very ambiguous
and perhaps
needs to have a better definition and i
think maybe one of the things you
suggested was a background check
i don't know if everyone else has a
concern or if we would be open to
amending that to be a little bit more
specific because i find that to be very
subjective
so i would assume
that if someone was not a good character
the department would tell the person
what where they flunked
yes and if i can clarify if you look up
at um
lines five and six well that whole
paragraph starting at three lines three
through six
what this paragraph is stating is that
the application shall include or be
accompanied by the following information
and documents so these are the types of
things that we would ask for more
information in the application and
that's where the background check would
come in in the application we could
require a background check but to
address your concerns about good
character
i did look into this a little bit
further
and in our tpa statute was which is the
third party administrator statute
it
instead of using the term good character
it says is competent trustworthy
financially responsible
or of good personal or business
reputation so that provides a little bit
more parameters but it wouldn't just be
a background check because the
background check is only going to give
you certain information we also would
want to make sure that
the people involved in running this type
of organization haven't had
you know administrative actions taken
against them before and that's the type
of thing that wouldn't necessarily come
up on like a criminal background check
so we want it to be a little bit more
broader than just you know a criminal
conviction or criminal background check
yes representative
yes i suppose i
like all of us we bring our backgrounds
and experiences with us and so i
perhaps have to apologize
but i'm still uncomfortable with leaving
this
the way it is is of good character and
would appreciate it if we could add
something to the effect
as per
uh
such and such a section in the tpa
or we can add that that whole phrase
that she just
or add that language
i mean i don't i don't care whether you
reference the tpa section or whether you
put it in of course if you put it in
that means it is what it is and it can't
it
you'd have to change it by statute
whereas if you reference to the tpa and
the tpa
is changed it's still referencing to the
tpa in the future as change i don't know
do you have a druthers on that the tpa
language i was referencing is in the tpa
statute so it would be a statutory
change either way i think it would be
cleaner to just amend the language here
to mirror the language
so okay can we do that we can
okay is that
do i need to move that
no because we don't have an amendment
we have to write it we have to write the
amendment okay and then we'll take that
i believe i have this scheduled
for next thursday is this another the
subcommittee would be rescheduled for
for this one might i ask representative
fargos is this am i just carrying this a
little farther in are you no i feel
you're happy with this now
where this is going i think i have a
much better comfort level i think the
amendment would answer that question for
me and i could support the bill at that
point yes
so could you make sure you said
yeah christine the uh the language yes
okay you got her you got her email now
or does she have your email
right okay
yeah
okay and then just as a follow-up from
yesterday i want to clarify to do my
homework for you we do have 26
registered
discount medical plans and they're
primarily offering prescription drug
discounts and dental services as well
and dental and we also want to clarify
that
these discount medical plans do not
include coupons for drugs there is a
distinction there so discount medical
plans the definition of them does not
include providers that give discounts on
their own products and services
so right i remember we had a build not
too long ago that we were going to ban
coupons
and i think i was
i was a minority
but fortunately
that never happened
okay you refresh my memory
is was this is this all new or did we
no we already have it you already have
so what were we changing here we're just
changing the um registration
requirements
there was no actual registration there
there was no action because they were
doing it they were doing it in thank you
they were required to register there
just weren't any requirements for what
that registration
you're putting some meat on the bones
for the registration yes and it mirrors
what's in the naic model
right
okay so anyway so we're um
needs
okay
what's next uh
121.
okay now we get down to some
the afternoon
okay
one pager
yeah
i'm just trying to see
in your pile like
okay
all right uh can you have a copy i can
just look down
this one
okay so this is another one of my name
is on it
okay
i think we all pretty much generally
agree we would not like the idea that
this happens without legislative right
input i agree
right everybody yes in addition to the
fact that i believe this was the the
bill where tyler
indicated that there would need to be a
give or take increase in staffing or
budget
so this goes this on two counts i think
this
goes uh back to for work
i was just trying to give a kind of a
comparison of the really the investment
the state would be doing when they if
they were to move forward with a
state-based exchange and that when you
look at if you ask the insurance
department to do that even at the low
cost of a kind of an implement
state-based implementation that would be
like a 50 increase in the insurance
department's budget but to the extent
that we as a state are spending money on
the exchange services
that's not an increase i mean hopefully
at the end of the day we're saving money
right
right but for the department
so
i mean i i guess when you try to think
about you know why you know how eight
well i could say is the institutional
knowledge how why we got where we were
and it was at that time when this was
first occurring was
um we were totally fearful of
of the software you know starting having
a nightmare good reason and i would say
then going forward when the last time
we were kind of discussing this issue
that
um in terms of the federal versus state
the issue was okay we could save money
but that but we're
we're somewhat vulnerable to a private
company maybe charging more fees not
like as i said on my county delegation
the one thing that drives us nuts is
that we upgrade our software and then
they keep sending us you know every year
we have to do the licensure and
licensing and the fees just they always
get higher right
and then but then i heard that for the
first time out of out of the blue and
that the federal government actually
reduced its fee
right
it actually reduced its fee so so so
that that gives you a nice right
were they increasing
did they didn't they decreased it and
then increased it uh it had been it so
it started low it had increased up to
about three and a half percent i think
yeah
and then they don't so
then under uh trump administration
dropped uh to the point where it's going
to be two and a quarter right now it's
increased back to two and a half and
it's almost time for them to announce
what next year's rate is going to be we
don't know right okay so theirs is
variable as well there's variable too
right so i would say
so one issue that where i was involved
in terms of the oversight committee
which i guess used to be
oversight over this and just so
everybody knows what that oversight
committee that was created by um the
former representative
manos
and his theory was that we didn't want
departments applying for waivers without
first having the legislature say whether
we think it's a good idea or not but
because the legislature can't always be
in session
that it was then to this this committee
this mother may i committee was that hhs
or the insurance department had to go to
this committee and get approval before
they can submit a waiver
request so that i guess the issue for me
was
that
um
it's always the balancing of you know
where we stand as the state do we you
know where we are the affordable care
act obviously we were there before
but this key element of the affordable
care act that really did change
was that the federal government was
going to subsidize individuals
and give them a discount you know give
them that subsidy and the question i was
always worried it was always in back of
my mind
is
the vulnerability of the state
of uh we're we're
have this program we have it set up
someone goes in and doesn't get it or
the federal government or some somehow
the the discount they didn't get their
discounted savings or something now the
state has to act as a advocate for that
citizen
against the federal model the federal
you know giving that rebate i mean you
follow where i'm going with this
that what do we call that discount what
do we call that
advanced premium tax credit it's
advanced premium tax credit okay
which is theoretically has to be
approved by a federal agency
right
can the state just say we're going to
give them this this advance without
having you know at some point in time
the federal government has to say yes or
no
that whatever we put it whatever the
software you got
who says this is what they're eligible
for
it does get turned up with your taxes so
that's one of the complexities of the
connection with irs
yeah it's um so it is what it is
advanced premium tax credit you estimate
your your income for the year either too
high or too low
then that advanced premium tax credit
wouldn't be accurate at the end of the
year you have to sell through so you get
like a 1099 or maybe some we gotta you
get a tax form on this
and then and then you just have to hope
that when you whatever withholdings you
had from
with your employer when you filled out
your w
poor
is that what you're saying that
withholding whether you're holding right
or not and then then you might have to
pay more or you gotta you get us get a
check back with you yeah i would say
that's a good way to think of your
advanced premium taxes it's a little
like you're withholding from your
paycheck you hope you're estimating
everything right but at the end of the
year when you file taxes you still may
need to make an adjustment
so if it was a state model versus a
federal model is that any different is
that still the same
so it's still the same and the state's
not in the middle of that the the
negotiation the
determination of the eligibility
uh
for the consumer for the citizen
of that tax credit is happening in the
technology system
so whether the technology system is the
federal system or the state-run system
that eligibility determination is
happening
and the
negotiation and the transfer of those
premium tax credits is happening between
the federal government and the insurance
carrier uh so it's happening behind the
scenes and the consumer
the individual taxpayer
and the individual uh
insured
uh individual
is not involved and the state is not
involved so
we wouldn't be we're not in the middle
of that
to your concern in terms of what i guess
my concern is software handling it
properly software inherently but
representative weston
come to the mic okay so yes why don't
you guys come up
well it might be the three of you
already i don't know yeah all three of
you needs to get out of here right
okay so
yeah so
it sounds like there are a number of
of uh of issues that fall out under this
question correct which suggests to me
that we're not quite ready yet for prime
time we might not want to and we're not
comfortable doing it this this way but i
might say philosophically
in addition to the fact that i don't
think it makes a whole lot of sense for
us to go back and
and and argue
um
what was argued back in 2010
insurance
historically has been
come under the
powers that are reserved to the states
not delegated to the federal government
but
we're already down this road and we
basically have a federal model now for
at least part of of the insurance
universe
so but but the option is is is given for
states
to to run their own um
which what was the right word here
exchange exchanges yes
um
the other item i think that that's
that's very
troublesome here is that
this bill is a signing the potential
studying the
the potential benefits of implementing a
state-based exchange to the insurance
department and we've already heard from
the insurance department that this would
be a real onerous burden upon them
in terms of time and and personnel and
and cost
so i i don't think this is a bad idea
and i actually like the idea of states
running exchanges
philosophically but i don't think we're
ready yet to do this
but again yeah so the the insurance
department would have to do the grunt
work if we put this to study
any way if we assign them the work of
doing this stuff who else would do who
else well that's a good question and
what did the other states do
did the other states assign their state
insurance departments to do this is
anybody can anybody answer that right
tyler's well first i'd comment that yeah
it would be it would be quite involved
for the insurance department to take the
lead on this and more likely than not we
would hire a contractor to assist the
state in doing it and we do have funds
in our budget but i think for an
investment like this this would be a
line item in our budget that would have
to show up separately in order for us to
really dedicate the resources necessary
but you're talking about a sort of very
involved process with a lot of
stakeholders and i can't underestimate
sort of dhhs's involvement in this
because of the medicaid program and the
tie to it but but interest will come out
i think on a number of different levels
and while we can act as a coordinator i
think beyond the resource concern is is
really sort of the insurance department
um weighing in with an opinion about
whether or not the state should move
forward that's uh that part we believe
that part we don't think you should no
you shouldn't be involved yeah but
that's the policy part that i think we
all agree
that you know that's that's our our job
to decide whether we should do it or not
so that gets down to uh
there are two ways to follow to study
this
my father so tyler do you know how other
states have handled this same question
at the at the at the at the
origin at the beginning pro of the
procedure i know there are small states
that that implemented
uh state exchanges
um
i came from rhode island
a number of years ago where rhode island
implemented a state exchange and had a
at the very get-go and had a lot of
problems a lot of problems
um
i don't know how they did that but i'm
thinking in terms of state budgets
what's available and
i would think comparably we're looking
at resources that
that are similar on a state level when
we look at new hampshire and rhode
island as opposed to new york or
california so can you answer
insurance regulation is structured
differently by state often it's combined
with different organizations new
hampshire being a smaller state
we're not we don't have some of the
entities that might exist in another
state i think health policy commissions
even in vermont you've got a green
mountain care board
so i think to the extent that a
responsibility like this would be
assigned to a particular entity it'd be
i'm not familiar with another state
insurance department being the lead
perhaps as an example like that but i
think more likely you're you're sort of
investing at the state level and kind of
an entity that's going to take the lead
on this and pull together all the
interested stakeholders um you may have
additional insight about how states sort
of move the forward process sure tyler i
would just add
i think idaho might be a good example
um idaho established a state-based
exchange um that they call your health
idaho
and they established that as a
stand-alone entity inside of the idaho
government
um i i
and and
you know we could be happy to share
additional information with you
it's also of course all available online
but as you think about studying this
whoever's performing that study
i think the one
piece of advice that i would suggest is
speaking to
other states that have gone through this
transition
because they've got that
naturally they have the expertise they
have the wisdom they have the experience
they can tell you what went well they
can tell you what didn't go well
they can weigh in on pitfalls things to
be on the lookout for
but idaho would be a good i think a good
sort of comparable
uh model i don't have a lot of insight
into how they handled it from a budget
standpoint uh but they would be a a
comparable a comparably sized state from
an exchange standpoint
my perception here is that this idea is
not running into a stone wall
thank you john
he's nodding his head sir yeah so so uh
i might ask a question of tyler then
to to do the kind of
uh checking at the 4 000 foot level
rather than at the at the ground level
on the way that other states
have gone about
uh proceeding with the state exchange
would that involve the same type of
process that you outlined before if you
were given full responsibility or would
this be a little bit easier and more
manageable and you could do it with the
resources that you have
i think if you're just doing if you're
asking basically just for an analysis of
how other states proceeded forward and
did the planning that's within the scope
of existing resources the report i gave
you the cover page in the executive
summary to yesterday and sent the link
around that was about a 15 000
expenditure for the department to have
them do basically a quick assessment of
the risks and opportunities and look a
little bit what other states did
mr chair do we have to make a formal
request or is this kind of like a person
to person
you to somebody or how do we do this i
guess it's it's we have to deal with the
legislation that's in front of us sure
okay so if we just interim study this
yes we could certainly ask the
department to do that yes okay
but key
what i'm hearing is the fiscal note
implication
okay
because theoretically
that uh anything they do
you know and they're going to want to
really to do it right you really need to
hire that outside consultant
okay and then anything they do
um how you know do we need do we need to
actually turn this bill into having an
appropriation for the department to
do this
analysis or uh you know so that's that's
where i guess we're um and then
obviously the issue was the way this
bill was written was to full steam ahead
yes okay which means that we are
agreeing to it which i think that pretty
much we're not we're not there yet but
you're saying if we want to interim
study this so that this kind of an
analysis can be done we have to make it
into a fiscal interim study
all the interim study is going to get to
is at the end of the day the interim
study is do we
do we go forward with some legislation
and then maybe draw up a potential it
used to be
um
go forward with a future men
as amended but i think they got rid of
that i think now we just have either go
forward or we don't go forward
that's that's the that's the motion of
anything that goes into rhythm study so
that the question is
if we're if we
that would be the least that would be uh
i guess the least impactful in terms of
certainly for us us to figure out how we
are with this at this moment otherwise
do we want to amend this bill
to
say
um to give the department money you know
amend the bill with an appropriation you
know or charge the the department with
going forward to doing that analysis
uh and creating potential legislation
so that the department will have
something have they get some work done
they'll have it and then we would then
see it come
january thank you um yes thank you i i
have some other concerns i mean i i
totally support where we're going with
this it's not ready for prime time in my
opinion um the question about interim
study do we have enough time to properly
do this study within the time frame that
that we have left
um because we're at the end of a term so
i'm concerned about that but i think
there's also some ambiguity in what
what we want out of the study it's not
just a software implementation there are
issues i think that need to be defined
like if we are going to have a cost
savings where will that money go
i mean they give you ideas like oh it
could go to general fund or it could go
here or there but i
really feel that before we could agree
to move forward we would have to define
where that savings would would go and
how it would be used and i
personally would like to see that it
somehow goes to reducing premiums or
you know
benefiting the consumer and none of that
is here this is a i heard the word
flexible and nimble and to me that was
like a red light going on because this
is just giving way too much
you know power to
to for decisions to be made that we're
not ready to make so
i'm i i have some serious concerns with
this bill in general so so you're you're
leading more to unexpedient to legislate
i would agree to moving
to to modifying it or amending it to
make it a study if
i'd be okay with with tyler going ahead
to do the analysis
but that that's all i would feel
comfortable with and i can't really
speak for the rest of
you
my concern is is again the resources
that tyler talked about in terms of of
doing that so
i i think that's real problematic
representative griezmann
i think representative fargo nailed it
on the head i'm i i can't shake my head
uh uh in the affirmative of what she
just said anymore um
i i like the idea of
getting a little bit more information of
how we go from what we have now
to a state exchange philosophically i'm
on board with that
but there's got to be a whole lot more
nuts and bolts in this before i would
there has to be separate legislation to
give the go-ahead i think we need to
define a little bit more clearly where
the savings are going to actually go and
it needs to go back to the people
because that's where the money came from
and uh so i i wrote on this little chart
not to be disrespective but uh
disrespectful but when he has on your
combining savings with federal matching
funds to support the existing
reinsurance program that's pie in the
sky
that's sales pitch
and and you know to save four million
dollars a year is six dollars and sixty
six cents per month per enrollee and i
don't know is that i mean that sounds
great four million dollars a year but uh
you know this is also not a time share
program uh and so when we get to the
maintenance costs what data is being
collected by whom and for what purposes
so there are just way too many questions
that we're going to have to answer to me
before i would ever go forward with
implementing it but i'm certainly not
opposed to doing it
if we get the answers right so how do we
do it how do we do it how do we do this
well
it's how how far do you want to go help
how far down we want to go i mean in
terms of
do we want to keep put
re changing this bill and writing all
that stuff in it or just interim study
it and let let us figure that out come
september
i i like this bill as it is written
right now
no way
that's what needs to be interim studied
okay it needs rewards interim study
would work for me we can get the right
answers and then we come up with
something if we get the right answers
yes okay but
this this is bigger than a bread box
interim study we don't have a lot of
time too well interim study would we you
know we have that month and a half
so what we would be doing in that month
and a half that's just revising this
perhaps a study
is well i it could end up coming out
that way but that it would have in it an
appropriation
for the department to do its analysis
work i think we're identifying specific
areas that we want addressed so i don't
think that that would take a lot of time
okay
i i think this could be i hope i'm not
being overly optimistic or unrealistic
here but i don't think that would really
take a lot of time because we know what
we're concerned about we know what we
want answers for we just da da da da da
we're done we can always make a
determination in interim study that we
don't want to move forward with this and
as well and save that and recommend it
for future and kill it so i before we
just walked away i do want to offer up
that um
that
former
senator
bragdon did point out and that what you
were reading there just that it was a
sort of a bone to me
and that was that um i was the uh one of
the negative votes
on the fact that we assessed everyone's
insurance everyone who had insurance for
all of us you know what they all the
fully insured
because
we all got assessed
uh and therefore we pay i don't know
it's a
couple dollars
a year i guess or a month
yeah okay so 250 that that turns into
like 30 bucks a year
so that we all all make a contribution
of 30 a year to help subsidize this
market so what he was appealing to me
was the savings would be to
uh either repeal that or
lower that dollar amount so that all of
us who are being taxed
to help subsidize this that we would get
the relief so i would just say in that
case
you're spelling out where was the
savings coming from that was spelled out
correct and so that it sounds like that
would probably be maybe stuck into
our recommendation uh come september
when we make it so
would it be appropriate to move to
interim study i think we've got enough
good heads to do this i'm making a
speech now but
um
representative
secondly representative greeson
is a
interim study
okay
did he just
yes yes your this is your last chance to
convince us not to do that no no not
trying to commit to a process question
i'm trying to remember exactly how
interim study works so uh the interim
study comes back with a report of we
urge uh we recommend pursuing this in
the subsequent year or we recommend not
doing it exactly and then when does that
interim study report have to come out
interim study has to end happen at the
end of october it's like november 1st or
something like that so there's nothing
that says people can't get together
between now and then and work on it
early if they anybody can work on it now
you know obviously obviously you know i
i would highly recommend you start
working on something so that by the time
we get to uh interim study next
september you've got something that you
would hope that we all can
right and plus not only the report
saying we should hopefully from our
perspective do something like this then
there's also the work on a bill to do it
which would have to be filed well so
we're we're
yeah but see we would say is uh again
you might be jumping the gun
that we would say is what you want to do
is uh is still going to be
spending the money that you need to have
an appropriation in it
for the department for the department to
hire its consultant to figure out what
this is going to cost and guarantee us
that we'll get savings over the future
right they got to they got to you know
give us the the risk analysis of how far
you know whether this really is
real or not
and give us the risk of you know what's
been but that whatever that all that
analysis work
actually to me is then wouldn't be able
to go into effect until after
we introduced this bill in january that
would have the appropriations so yes
we're definitely pushing everything off
a year here okay because in that bill it
would then have the appropriation it
would have where the money's going to go
what we're going to do you know what's
what's you know and and so then that
gets signed it gets put in the budget
for next year
okay so
assuming that we you know that they come
the the department gets everything done
you know some through 2023 you know
through the so the fall of 2023
so that means come
no new legislation would actually come
in to actually implement it if it were
to happen
would be january of 2024.
and i want to make sure i understand
giant 2024 would be beginning of the
bill that would actually got it get the
us to buy into
so
with that point we'll have a fiscal note
that says what the what this is really
going to do the bill for 2023
is an appropriation of the department
appropriation and guidelines about what
we're going to do and what are our
expectations about doing this
because they have a small appropriation
now that could do a few little things
but to do the big thing we need a lot
more in a specific lineup
and also the guidelines from us from
wanting whether we're you know and then
and then we have then you have the
legislature a body and we're happy to
provide any assistance or resources you
might need on that is that everybody so
are we feeling are you feeling are you
all feeling comfortable
with the uh the areas that we've
identified as areas of concern for us so
that you don't walk out of here and and
say i don't really know what they were
talking about oh no i think those are
all legitimate concerns and questions
that uh come up i'm sure often in other
states as well okay and uh yeah and you
know maybe others but those were pretty
clear okay i think tyler just started
the countdown to win his retirement
start
now he can't retire we've already lost
too many people in in the insurance
department we can't have him retired too
soon
the other comment that i might make with
respect we can't predict who's going to
be here
a year or two from now
but
what you're hearing is
interest on both sides
yes so that ought to provide you with
some degree of encouragement that you're
not going to go on a fool's errand in
case
the legislature flips to the one thing
i've been we've been very impressed by
is the bipartisan support for the
concept right the details the hammer out
but the concept i've been very impressed
by the and you see your sponsor list is
a bipartisan list of sponsors so
yes okay
so the motion is uh in room study is the
motion clear all those in favor raise
your hand
one two three four five
okay
beautiful
all right
all right next is 319.
okay
here we go
um
okay
all right
what what are people thinking about this
bill i mean we got a lot of negative
letters but that doesn't necessarily
mean
too much other than some people
found out that they can send emails to
us legislators
so you have a representative burroughs
you have a yeah i know that this bill is
likely going to go down in here but i
will just say that um i do think that
this sets an important precedent um
whether covet comes back or some some
other similar
we get some other similar virus in the
future i think it's important that
insurance companies be able to provide
these incentives like we talked about
the wellness incentives for going to a
gym or whatnot and um i think this will
keep our
our insurance costs lower for everyone
and ensures that we have more beds in
our hospitals when such a pandemic takes
place
right so and i and i was you know
thinking about that too because i that's
i kept saying you know the health you
know this um the gym gym thing and so
evidently we do have something in our
statute now about these wellness
yes you need to turn the mic on
tyler
yeah the right so wellness programs are
committed most of the guidance is
federal um and uh but it is an
opportunity as as long as it's not
discriminatory that
carriers can embrace sort of a wellness
type program that um encourages you to
do something and hopefully ends up with
lower costs
so the feds are the ones who really to
blame for making this a fuzzy issue
is that correct um i wouldn't put too
much blame on them i think it does come
back to just sort of the fundamental way
the way insurance works and um and with
all the particularly since the aca
passed protections around pre-existing
conditions protections around sort of
consideration of health factors and
nobody really seems to want to see a
wellness program that really is based on
how healthy you are not what you're
doing
so that's um that would be the concern
about uh sort of any type of new vaccine
or
incentive type arrangement that's tied
to it i mean is that a health factor or
is it something the person did
and if it's something they did it's
wellness if it's something that reflects
their health status that's more like a
health factor and prohibited
and that's something the legislature
should
decide we should sort that out uh you
know try not to provide kind of an
opinion around what the legislature
should and shouldn't do but no i'm
saying i'm saying
is it at the end of the day is that
something that we really you know that
well they say we need to do it is that
it is appropriate for the legislature to
to referee this
so i'm and i'm saying thinking about
what representative rogers has said is
what happens going forward okay good you
know yeah it's you know that because i i
hear that that there will be another
coveted pandemic probably within the
next 10 years so we how do we do
preventive legislation now so that when
that occurs that we don't have this
issue again yeah i think that
legislation like this does send the
message that
a wellness program is structured like
this is acceptable to the new hampshire
legislature so um
i think that uh you know the
department's in a place where we're
looking at that federal guidance we're
looking at potentially discriminatory
practices but i think if a program like
this today was developed
we would not be in a position to object
to it i'm not sure how much interest
there is from the carriers at the moment
but then again this is a potentially
competitive area if there is a carry
that wants to offer this to clients
wants the clarification and they're the
only one they may not want to actually
make that public
um i mean this you know you're kind of
um
how about the exchange i mean the the
marketplace i was thinking we're
supposed to call it the marketplace yeah
isn't the is the marketplace included
because that's federally
right so remember what i said about
wellness programs in general they're
they're they're permissible for the
group market but most of the time we're
talking about the exchange we're talking
about the individual market right you
kind of get your small employer coverage
there so it's
i think we're it's a different
definitely a different set of issues so
would it qualify for the individual
market no you would not be able to do a
wellness program like this for the
individual market um or a wellness
program more generally
so that's this that is what i hate more
than anything else if we go past
something and then and then find out
there's a big chunk of people who can't
take advantage of it and then and then
we'll get the letters saying why can't
we right
so representative burroughs i'll just
say one thing and and i'm prejudiced
because i i will say this i'm married to
a health care consultant
who
talked to about this and our system is
based on a sickness model rather than a
wellness one and we're 30 i think it's
37th in the world in terms of our life
expectancy and our health institutions
make more money when we're sick rather
than doing preventative care and i think
that this
thank you
i think that this really falls into that
and i really think um um that we need to
switch over to the wellness model and
there's there's so many things that
hospitals and local health care centers
can be doing
um i i agree i want to be clear this
isn't the mandate this is
they may do it it's voluntary it's not
telling anyone you have to it's just
giving people
an incentive and i heard representative
van houghton yesterday if we saved one
life because someone got the vaccine
to take advantage of this then
that's a good thing so
i don't have a problem with this bill
and i'm going to support it
okay
um i think
it in my mind it's uh appropriate to
interim study it so that we can least
look at this wellness
concept
and and not just as vaccines
but in overall
wellness
so you had your hand up and yes you
wanted to say so
question
each flu season i receive an incentive
from my
insurance company which is now medicare
to go and get a flu shot because and
they're free what's the incentive to get
the incentive is that i don't have to
pay for it and i'm supposed to be
preventing
getting the flu
and they're not going to charge me for
it so were co did people pay for their
covet shots
well
uh
so if you don't want to get sick
and you don't have to pay for something
to my mind that's that's incentive
enough without having to offer people
another fifty dollars
um
i've already gotten in trouble once this
week for speaking my mind so i'm just
going to be very diplomatic and say
uh i i think we we have sufficient
incentives already
uh for people to do what they would
choose to do
because um what i've just heard is you
have to pay for it anyway so thank you
okay representative
oh where to begin on this one
okay representative griezmann makes a
motion people need to legislate this
let's cut to the church no no this is
itl that's what i said people speak to
legislation oh i'm sorry i thought you
said interviews no i i know i look like
a quick study people people who eat
right and exercise
and do all the quote healthy things
still get diseases and die
people who eat multiple buckets of
chicken a day
and smoke
multiple packs of cigarettes a day
consume copious amounts of alcohol
never even consider looking at a
treadmill let alone walking on one
lived to be 90 something years old
there are people who did not get
vaccinated and did not die
they got coveted and they got over it
maybe they didn't get coveted at all we
don't know
you cannot prove
in any way shape or form that the
vaccine saved a life
because it would have to have been
administered
when you are in your death throes they
shoot it in your veins
and then poof magically you're alive
again
and that never happened it you cannot
show where it saved a life did it i i
got sick
i saved
multiple tens of thousands of dollars
because i didn't go to the hospital do i
get an incentive
i wasn't on a ventilator i didn't get
rem deserver i didn't put anybody out
but i also didn't get an opportunity to
go get my cancer screenings or any of
those other health checkups for over a
year because my doctor wasn't even
seeing in his patients because i didn't
have covet at the time this is all a
bunch of poppycock
okay mr chairman
it's a little bit late but i was going
to caution my my colleague and dear
friend a little bit earlier on he's
going to get in trouble again
okay
d.o.h does that stand for itl all right
so uh
okay so representative greeson second by
representative moves in experience the
legislate and um i i will vote for this
motion but i'll tell you the reason why
i'm voting for this motion is that is
the itl motion i will vote for it
because
um two reasons one is i think it's a
little johnny come lately with this bill
because i think too it's it's a little
it's old news now but more importantly i
actually frankly
don't think the incentive is is the
issue at this point because i think
anybody
who would have gotten the vaccine
would have gotten it okay and to
suddenly pass this legislation to say
okay by the way some insurance company
could decide that they're going to give
you an incentive to do it
i don't think it will change anybody's
mind that those people all those people
who refuse to get it are going to still
refuse to get it i mean i i've never
heard more cockamamie ideas about why
not to get the vaccine
just for the record
i think everyone should have a vaccine i
have no doubt in my mind that the
vaccine absolutely reduced the amount of
people who went into a hospital okay now
i realize that you might not agree with
me on this all right but that is my
personal opinion that everyone should
have gotten the vaccine and will and
right now i'm just discussing with my
wife
when i should get my second booster and
i was kind of holding out for next fall
thinking that that's the time that i
would probably need a booster but i know
i will need one okay but i understand
that's my personal opinion and that's
where i am
and i just think this bill
has
huge consequences and that's why i think
studying it and trying to figure out how
we address this issue of wellness i
think is very worthy and and i would
have kept uh you know keep it around and
work on it but
clearly
that it's not the mood that i get from
this subject you could change your mind
so there are other ways to study
wellness without using the vehicle of
this bill
i'm ready to vote mr chairman
any more discussion on the motion have
been expedient to legislate
all right seeing then all those in favor
raise your hand one two three all those
opposed
all those opposed
the vote is three to two
okay
mr chair i have to go testify
all right so representative weston you
were
you're on
okay
all right next up establishing committee
to study the oversight and operation of
the public deposit investment pool so
this is our last one
all right
okay so let me see who do i have i get
it all right uh
grayson
um
okay so terry
and we have fargo and weston
okay so i just got off the phone this
morning
with former bank commissioner
and uh absolutely is true uh actually he
gave me the history because i always
liked the history let's start with the
history
okay
uh evidently this legislation was passed
on my my very first
first term on this committee
so that puts it back in 1989
89.
my very first term just for the record
my very first term i was on science and
technology
and uh they had about 19 bills and they
were all anti-seabrook and i just
couldn't get off that committee fast
enough
so so uh now that was long before ready
i mean actually i knew rennie at the
time because uh i was also a member of
ratepayers rights
and and which he was a part of the
organization so i get to read i met bob
bacchus and and randy cushing long
before i ever got into the legislature
because i i agree that we shouldn't be
sticking people with a creep it was
having construction work in progress was
was definitely a problem
anyway
um this bill uh this law was passed by
uh roland beau rivera who was the bank
commissioner at the time
his wife was a state senator if i
remember correctly sheila
and um he came in and said uh this is
about this is back when the big the
first banking crisis you know this is we
all i think we we blame this banking
crisis actually on ronnie reagan and
rostankowski because of the tax act
that was changed in 1988 and in that tax
act they took away the deductibility of
mortgage deductions and not worrying
about business corporate write-offs
and uh and so that was a dramatic impact
and then it was fearful that our banks
were going to
lose money hand over fists and that
would mean all these municipalities
the
municipalities are going to get caught
in the middle of you know that they
would pass on those losses
to to to those people and uh
so and i and and we did have i mean
obviously the original bank of new
hampshire i think failed at that at that
time or had to be regarding yeah so i
think you know the same anything so i
think so i think there was some truth in
what he was saying that that we need to
do that
um so
when
we were discussing this uh in in terms
of the fact that yes you know the
banking department
um did you guys do any homework about
you know what other states do did you
were you able to
okay yeah why don't you come and talk to
us and uh in terms of other states
nobody else
no one else thought it was a great idea
for the banking department and i'm sure
that the only person who thought it was
a great idea was roland roberts at the
time
he was financial institutions they said
right
so so based on our research um there are
45 local government um investment pools
within the united states
and
as i said yesterday new hampshire is
the only state which is housed under the
authority of the banking department for
oversight the
majority of the states um that have
these they're under the state treasurer
i think that
about 40 of them otherwise there are in
municipal sort of like local government
uh boards but majority is the state
treasurer that oversees
this i did provide um
i emailed it on to the committee so i
apologize i did it but so the majority
is under state treasurer's office but we
have a breakdown list of each state on
the name of it as well it's where it is
right okay
so um
the upshot is that yes that what we
really want to do is two things
a is we want to move it out of banking
and put it under the state treasurer's
office
and b
we want to
um
we really want the municipal association
the people who are the the ones who are
making these deposits we want to
restructure it so that this is really
their entity not necessarily a state
entity uh and just kind of you know get
it as uh
much like other states do in terms of
who who should be operating it so that's
pretty much that's where the the where i
ended it with the conversation with
jerry that's where i walked away not
saying that that was his idea but i'm
gonna i'm gonna own it that that was
what i might where i'm at at this moment
thinking that we we um the way the
bill's written now it talks about how
whether the banking department should
still
be involved
um
a
but it doesn't really talk about this
concept that i'm i'm i'm promoting is
that at some point in time we need to re
we need to separate it from
uh this is sort of a a spin-off we need
to spin this off as a separate entity so
uh i guess
for those who who care about this bill
ryan
would you want to do that as an interim
study or would you want to do it as
rewrite this
rewrite this bill to
give it those guidelines and have a a
joint house and senate
okay so in other words
basically
we would i the problem i have with the
language as it is right now and
obviously i'm speaking for myself so
other members of the committee might
have a different opinion is that i think
we need to give a more
powerful charge
to that committee
okay in terms of a tasking
okay the tasking say we are saying we
want this to be
um
moved out of banking
moved into
the treasurer's office
a and b
we want it to
have
the appropriate um you know
the entities really be changing it
rather than this being the state you
know calling it bp dip right or that it
needs to be set up like other states
have done which is the the board of
directors is the municipal the
associations that are are the ones who
are using it
it could still be it could be any one of
the three
okay
all right all right so how did rather
what are you thinking when you said when
you say keeping it as a study you mean
the bill rather
he wants to get senators by him so i i i
think well once again uh speaking
personally
as you did uh mr chairman uh i i agree
with your sentiments i i think we ought
to in this case
uh
thank the uh
the representations that that we see uh
from other states as being
instructive and inspirational with
respect to a change here
the way we do this in new hampshire
prior to
coming in this morning i was thinking
about this and thought yes it should be
the treasure
this would be come under the treasure
and whose responsibility is is overall
oversight of funds here in new hampshire
and um
uh the depositors if you will this our
favorite word these days is stakeholders
how they're appointed or elected
um i'm not down to that level yet but it
needs to be a representative
group
and i think that that whether they're
appointed or they're elected we can
debate that um but it ought to be that
group that government that governance
yes to govern yes
representative peace
am i understanding correctly that the
the fund this this p-dip
function
p dip
uh is not just
municipalities but there are some
private entities that have
monies in there that are managed no no
no private no private no
whose money is actually in there because
what i would be concerned about with you
know with with the management or the
control of these funds
is
you have
municipals uh you know you go for
anywhere from manchester to wentworth
new hampshire
and i would hate to see a whole bunch of
wentworths being dominated by the
interests of a manchester uh you know
and so it just becomes a steamroll we're
going to manage the way we want to
manage it
take it take it or leave it so there
needs to make sure that that whoever is
going to have oversight over this um
is truly representative of all of the
depositors
the stakeholders whatever i hate that
term but anyway
uh so so and then i also would want to
make sure that
uh given that there and i don't know if
it's if it's already codified somewhere
in statute i haven't seen it but i know
that the an executive order presidential
executive order uh was done back in uh
january of last year that removed a
requirement
that these types of managers
had a fiduciary responsibility to the
investors
so that they they uh it was it was
removed
uh and therefore would leave vulnerable
because it would allow them to make
financial decisions and investments that
may or may not actually be to the best
interest of the investor but that would
pursue
some other
uh motivation so the return on the
investment is not always guaranteed to
be maximized unless it is by the
direction of the depositor who may say i
want it to go in that direction versus
another way so i i want to make sure
that whoever is managing these funds is
actually obligated to to maximize the
return and i'm not saying that's not a
criticism of who's who's handling it now
uh i i don't know
um
but
my concern is is to make sure that they
are obligated to be fiduciaries
of this money
obligated to the investor i think i
think they're pretty well well i don't
want pretty well i want it codified in
law
okay well i mean i bet you if you only
because in the law now this is only
because of the presidential executive
what does it say in the
what does it say in your pdip now does
it say anything about
investment responsibilities in the in
the current
but is that written in the statute or is
that written in the only in that
agreement you have with the people who
are doing the uh
yeah and again it's only because of the
exact the presidential executive order
that that was removed
that that that was that requirement was
was was removed and so i want to make
sure that it that we are making sure
that they have that obligation i know
that i think i know what you're
referring to
from the standpoint of being an
individual investor there was a big
debate around that and i i'd have to go
back and do the research on that
um mr chair about on the issue of
representation
on the
commission or committee right and
speaking to representative greeson's
concern about small
banks or investors
uh not being represented i think as we
get down now drill down deeper here
that we might want to
consider if we
if we're not going to be the appointed
body
or the treasurer is is not that we if we
have that concern that we need to be
specific about that
in terms of providing uh the the the
requirements as to
uh
who shall
be represented
you know and getting
there shall be representatives from
uh banking or institutions or
municipalities of
a small medium and large size
i'm just thinking of sodas right now so
here's here
that is that i think that addresses
representative griezmann's concern if in
fact there would be an issue that the
the larger municipalities and banks
would dominate if they
were appointed or particularly if they
were elected and that the the smaller
community smaller institutions smaller
municipalities could could be left out
we've seen this happen over and over
again so i just wanted to think about
that i think you guys should have a
little bit of the cart to get ahead of
the
yeah the whole the horses
because
what i'm thinking is the same issue we
had before with it with the
state-based thing
all we're saying at this point is that
we want to create a study committee
that is charged to go look what these
other 44
entities look like and pick one
and recommend it for future legislation
come january at that point in time
you can then make make sure you get the
fiscal responsibilities written into
that statute when we revise that bill
yes and what we're doing is we're
already starting to do that work so i
agree with you yes okay back on the
prior question yes okay
how does everybody feel about that
that makes sense that we would just go
back and look at what other states are
doing and
and and uh and charge a
a
a legislative study committee
three house number three centers
and uh and just gonna revise that
language to really tell them to focus in
on
um
looking at what other states have
accomplished or doing
um and and whether we go ahead and say
state treasurer like uh you know we
could probably say that
so
would you suggest then an amendment to
this yes
now
my real concern on is this date this
delivery date of november 1st of 2022
right so basically what we would be
doing is this would be a study committee
that would meet this fall
now this would be outside because it's
not in a room study this would be
outside of our committee right so uh
three selected people would be chosen
and i know representative mcalee has
already told me that he wants to be the
dem
and uh and for the house side and uh we
would uh basically they would then go
and look at all the different options
that are out there
uh in terms of what other states are
doing okay and then and then pick and
choose which one they like best and then
that would come in as legislation for
come next january okay so you'll draft
an amendment to this that we can move
this along now and we can keep this date
that date exactly
okay represented that would work
i think with inflation being at maximum
levels uh rate of return is going to be
an issue because municipal budgets are
going to get steamrollered with uh
with inflation so rate of return would
be something i would be interested in in
these other 40 states is that possible
to collect maybe that data
yes i could see you typically uh the
their public annual reports so i can
look through and see if i could find it
yeah there are republic reports yeah
that they would have in the various
other states
include that in the charge of the study
committee
uh
as that's one of the things to look at
yes yeah i got that right
because you're in charge of writing this
amendment
but just to note um a star presented
please question regarding fiduciary
obligations there is the um so there's
federal law that also
is so like the investment advisor act of
1940 these investment advisors
oh a fiduciary obligation as well as
then is delineated within the contracts
and our rfp
okay
so so of course uh
you referenced what the federal um the
investment advisory act of 1940 so
there's securities laws which require
investment advisors in this case pfm
to
uphold certain fiduciary obligations um
as well as in our rfs all investment
advisors yes yes and they are so are you
familiar with what representative
greeson was alluding to or describing
and that i
confirmed is that
there was a change that was made within
the last couple two or three years
where
financial firms did not have to to be
fiduciaries any longer
so my understanding um not i am not
there was a big debate around that and
you're not familiar with that no i don't
okay well not like i've never heard
we'll need well
yes you need to let us see that so we'll
need to interact with you on that so
that you're aware of that because
because if there's a federal statute and
it applies and then i don't understand
what happened then we'll need to get to
the bottom of that thank you and then
it's also addressed in our contracts too
so that would override well that that
would override i mean yes
okay
so we'll not take action on this and
we'll wait have the amendment and take
action on this next thursday and what
i'll do is you'll get me that
we'll start working on this over the
weekend so we can get something out to
everybody
sooner rather than later okay
all right that's it
i think we're done
whoops actually stuck
you
yeah
everybody
if they don't i'll blame you
you know we went on yesterday so right
okay
yes
thank you
um
time
is
so
i just want to make sure
all right
we'll catch it all right
yes
i didn't take the call when you fall
okay
just ask me that um i see him in the um
i see him in the
convenience store post office
do you want to hear my funny jeans just
here
i just told him
yes
because they're
all yeah
is
today
[Music]
yes
right
this
there could
wow
so now i know
out there
it's in your perspective
um
is
oh
i
it's all good
yes
is
oh
okay
is
um
uh
okay i'll sort it out
oh you want to be tag team okay all
right
okay
all right
we want to start on time because i got
to get out of here and head down south
for my son's wedding this weekend
all right we're out by tomorrow
indian names are
okay
uh so 160. senate bill 160 and we'll
hear from
uh grant bossie who will who's standing
in for senator bradley who is uh
sitting in an airport in florida
waiting to get a flight
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee uh the red sox and yankees uh
got canceled because the weather today
so did the senate majority leader uh he
appreciates your understanding and
courtesy my name is grant bosse with the
new hampshire senate here to introduce
senate bill 160 fn on behalf of its
prime sponsor senator jeb bradley this
bill deals with multiple employer
welfare arrangements or miwas currently
several multiple employer welfare
arrangements exist in new hampshire this
bill would strengthen the existing
statutes concerning me was the federal
department of labor rule permitting the
expansion of these arrangements is
currently suspended however if there
were ever reinstated new hampshire would
find itself at a competitive
disadvantage
in committee at the request of the new
hampshire bankers association the
committee amendment removed line 19 on
page two of the original bill to ensure
that existing plans are not
inadvertently impacted or forced to
dissolve
if you have any questions i would defer
to
others testifying or i can get your
questions to senator bradley
and make sure he gets an answer back to
you
we ask for your consideration in support
of senate bill 160. thank you
great and we appreciate that written
testimony because
i definitely don't have a clerk
fair enough thank you thank you
any questions here for
yeah yes representative herbert question
you do know what amiiwa is right
okay
put your light on
um
senator bradley there are no other
co-authors or sponsors of this
legislation
i believe he was the prime i don't know
if there were co-sponsors i don't know
evidently he was the only sponsor yeah
evidently he was the only sponsor okay
thank you
yes
that was an easy question
okay so just everybody knows what amir
is um
thank you again thank you
actually
who else is testifying on this bill
okay curtis
so
curtis is on his way yes
as someone new can someone explain to me
what i'll explain okay thank you okay
so um
let's see uh
who else was in the room when this
happened
senate bill 711.
tara were you in the house when yeah so
tara and i were
in this room
when uh 7-eleven was introduced which is
the uh the original affordable care
action for new hampshire and um there
was when you're trying to
when we tried the law that senator
shaheen
sponsored
the meewa was
organizations that already pre-existed
the organization had pre-existed
prior to
our reform of the
statute in terms of community rating and
what it was occurred so there was the
the bankers
the auto dealers
and
the motor transport
can't forget the motor transport
and they um all three of them had
a health insurance plan
that was created
by that organization so we had a carve
out of the legislation that allow
for this miwas which is multiple
employer
so you have multiple employers you know
when you think of a car dealer then
multiple car dealerships multi-employer
the organization and the bankers
association same thing that they were
they were coming together they had an
association so that was the one of the
most important things the association
had to exist
prior to it and that they happened to
come together and have a health
insurance product and they would be
exempt from the uh 7-eleven and the
community rating requirement and
everything because they would do that
within themselves within the
organization but the key number there
was 3 000 lives
and that's very important to remember
the 3000 lies because often when we came
back to revisit this legislature
years and every year it was always about
um
what was the uh the
key element that made them legitimately
separate you know for him to be out
exempted out of the statute and um
so now curtis berries uh who represents
the uh retail association
who at the time did not have amiibo
created and have always thought about
creating amiwa and we've always been
told is as long as you have three
thousand lives you could you could join
the club
thank you mr chair uh and good afternoon
members of the committee i am curtis
barry here on behalf of the new
hampshire retail association
first to remind you that retail
association in new hampshire is made up
of both
large national chains and several
hundred new hampshire-based businesses
and it's on behalf of that the latter
group
that i appear here today uh before i
begin my very brief remarks um in
response to the the
observation that there's just one
sponsor of the bill
i'll point out that the bill came out of
the senate committee five to nothing
with five to nothing ought to pass
recommendation and passed on a voice
vote so seem to have fairly unanimous
support over in the senate
among the small business members of the
retail association
one thing that they've said to me that
i've heard in this is my 23rd year
representing the association it's been
fairly consistent among the top if not
the number one impediment to hiring
people
is the rapidly rising cost of health
insurance premiums to provide the
benefit for their employees
this year
that's exacerbated by the fact that
they're having to pay
10 percent 15 20 more just to hire
people and yet the small the small group
insurance premiums they're experiencing
are north of 10 increases year over year
and unfortunately what that means is
when they're providing a benefit
they're reducing the benefit that
they're provided possibly they're
passing along some of the increased
costs to their employees in higher
co-pays higher co-insurance those sorts
of things
so it's a shared cost that seems to be
really unsustainable
i'm glad mr chair that you answered that
question because i'm certainly no expert
in me was or association health plans
and i guess my testimony is focused on
the purpose which is to help small
business attain a more affordable health
care coverage and new coverage options
uh so that they can continue to provide
a robust health insurance plan benefit
for their employees i'm happy to answer
questions but i'm going to guess the
insurance department's going to be much
better qualified than i am
and they're not here m.i.a oh okay did
you put a card in
oh
okay no rock yes
well thank you for bringing those over
for me
thank you
any questions for curtis berry yes
representative abel yes thank you it's
good to see you um and thank you for
testifying uh could you give us an idea
of the approximate number of
smaller businesses that might be in this
association in our association your
association yes um we the association
has
900 member i think a little bit over 900
member locations
um in
90 the last time i checked around 90
percent of them were new hampshire-based
businesses
thank you
thank you very much thank you
okay now michelle eaton from the
insurance department
who takes no position on the bill
good afternoon my name is michelle
heaton i'm the health law and policy
legal counsel with the
new hampshire insurance department as
you said we don't take a position on
this bill but we're here to provide some
background information and answer
questions i gather a lot of you may have
about me was
so just to give you a little bit of
background
amiwa is a multiple employer welfare
arrangement and this is defined in
federal statute under the urissa law
which is department of labor is the one
who oversees it
and miwas are
employee welfare benefit plans or other
arrangements which are established or
maintained for the purpose of offering
or providing health benefits to eligible
employees of two or more employers to
their beneficiaries
a lot of confusion comes about between
what a miwa and an ahp an association
health plan is an association health
plan is a type of miwa so they are very
similar in
but we use different terms to talk about
and part of that is because
in june of 2018 the department of labor
promulgated rules that expanded the
definition of employer
these rules were later
11 states in the district of columbia
challenged these rules and on march 29
2019 the u.s district court
in the district of columbia issued an
order vacating
the bona fide association and working
owner provisions of those rules
they found that those rules exceeded
what has already been defined in the
erisa statute of what an employer is
so at that time the decision was
appealed and it was pending appeal when
the administration changed once the
biden administration came in they filed
an abeyance so currently that is still
held in advance since there's a new
administration they're evaluating what
to do
so that's where the idea of association
health plans came about and that's where
a lot of that terminology came so there
was a period of time where there was
this expanded opportunity where these
association health plans would qualify
as a miwa
that's kind of what this bill i believe
is addressing so to the extent that that
court decision were to later be appealed
and overturned or the department of
labor were to go back and do rule making
to adjust those definitions maybe to
better comply with what's in the orisa
statute
this bill or
our law would be in place to address
those issues so
me was
it's a very complicated
subject
so i will try my best to answer your
questions
but that just gives you a little bit of
background i just one more thing i want
to point out is that your ability to
establish a miwa does not necessarily
equate your ability to purchase group
insurance especially when we're talking
about major medical insurance
in order to qualify as a large group
that large group definition is in the
public health statute not in orissa
statute and that public health statute
says that it has to be an
employer of
50 or more
50-plus employees in order to qualify as
large group
so that's different and i think some of
the confusion where this comes about is
that there's a lot of smaller employers
that would like to band together
to create a miwa thinking that they're
going to get this large group rate and
that's not the way it works
even if you're can band together as a
miwa you're still rated at the amount of
employees each individual employer has
so they still would be rated as a small
group
so those are some of the highlights but
i'd be happy to answer any questions
okay so my question is this is how many
pages here
so at the end of the day
the
um
not to be confused with me was and not
to be confused
um
the idea the original idea of the
affiliations was uh is could a chamber
of commerce
have all its members join because
they're all members of the chamber could
they then do a health
arrangement so what's in this bill
as
pertain to that
political concept
so this bill amends
again we did not draft the spill so
we're just here to provide
some background information but the idea
is that a chamber of commerce if under
the department of labor rules that this
court has set aside
would have allowed like a chamber of
commerce to get its members together to
develop this i this this group employer
so it is expanding the definition of
employer and
part of what was set aside in those
rules too is that an employer could be
a self-employed individual
that is different than the way that was
the realtors wanted that one yeah so
that's different than what how the
department of labor had previously been
interpreting that it had to be an
employee you as a sole proprietor plus
one employee right so this would allow a
lot of sole proprietors to band together
to establish a group
but
those rules have been
held in advance for now
see that's a legal term that i don't
know what that means that means the
rules were struck down the certain
portions of the rules so those portions
relating to the definition of an
employer were struck down and are not
enforceable and the appeal is just being
held so it hasn't been vacated it could
still proceed but right now the
government has asked that we just put a
hold on things while they reassess the
situation and it could be that they do
eventually decide to move forward with
that appeal or they could go back and
amend their rules through rulemaking
there's a lot of indecision right now
but if this bill is being passed an
expectation of this issue being resolved
i guess i want to know what what was the
outcome out of you know
what is the outcome of this bill and
what is it saying is it is it allowable
for our chamber commerce to organize and
create an affiliation
of course under new hampshire law they
need to have 3 000 lives
is that still in here it's 3 000 lies
still in here i mean there's a lot of
pages here you expect me to read this
the way it
has bona fide pathway one and po bona
fide pathway two that's what mirrors
those department of labor rules and the
bona fide pathway too has a number of
factors so it could be the chamber of
commerce doesn't even necessarily meet
the pathway to requirements it's a
case-by-case determination based on the
facts of the association and there's a
number of factors that go into it i
think the idea with this bill is that if
it passes
in the current state it's not going to
really change much but if the
the federal rules issue gets resolved we
will have something in place that would
allow those types of associations and i
also want to point out that they'll
allow it that's yeah
would allow it
so
our meanwhile law that's currently in
place right now is only applicable to a
self-funded miwa so if you're a miwa but
you're purchasing commercial insurance
our meal is not even applicable to you
you're more of a purchasing alliance we
have a separate statute for that
and so this would only be for
self-funded and the reason we regulate
the cell phone is because we want to
make sure their financials are in order
and but they're also regulated at the
federal level through the um
department of labor because they would
be erisa plans as well okay
representative herbert has a question
my question is
i heard somebody talk about the fact
that you know there was an
expense expenses have gone up
most recently and it's becoming more
less affordable to have the same type of
benefit
so my question to you is if the federal
government took over the universal
health care and made universal health
care and took all those expenses off the
budget
of the of these various businesses would
they like that
not really in a position to comment on
that i think the answer is pretty clear
okay
anyone else
thank you very much
okay
here's her what else do i have i don't
have any more cards right
that's it does anybody else want to
testify
okay we will oh
how about do we have the overnight
blue sheets
chris
the computer
okay we'll we won't worry but uh in
committee we only had one saying one
name
and she already spoke so uh well that i
will close the public hearing
and um
hopefully tyler will be around for the
the stuff when we do this we will be
subbing this next week
okay
right so the big is you know what's the
actual outcome you know what what what
side is this fall on
or or is it just simply
whichever way the court comes out this
will allow it to happen
that's what i love about a lawyer that's
what i love about lawyers
we have a running joke in this committee
ask
five lawyers and you get six answers
then you're gonna have to fix it in the
rule rulemaking right
okay
all right next bill
373 relative to coverage for certain
mental illness okay 373 we'll start out
with grant
thank you
mr chairman members of the committee i
remain not jeb bradley
my name is grant bosse with the new
hampshire senate here to introduce
senate bill 373 on behalf of senator
bradley its prime sponsor senator
bradley introduced this bill at the
request of the insurance department to
require that insurers submit a mental
health benefit comparative analysis
consistent with federal requirements to
ensure they are in compliance with
mental health parity requirements
the bill also removes a state
permissible maximum coverage cap for
autism
this section would be preempted by
federal mental health parity laws but
could cause confusion if it were left in
the state statute the bill also removes
the requirement that the department
develop rules for autism coverage opting
for the enabling may language instead
existing federal rules provide the
necessary regulatory structure at this
time michelle heaton of the insurance
department is here to give us more
complete understanding of the changes
and i would defer any questions of the
committee to her thank you for
consideration of this legislation
senator bradley asks for your support of
senate bill 373.
great thank you very much thank you
and uh
got a card this time
michelle heaton from the insurance
department
hello again again
i'm michelle heaton from the new
hampshire insurance department i'm the
health law and policy legal counsel
so we requested this legislation and are
in support there are three parts to this
bill
but the last two are more essentially
administrative cleanups
so for the first part new hampshire was
one of the first states to perform a
market conduct examination related to
health parity compliance at the end of
the exam two years ago
we entered into a monitor monitoring
agreements with anthem and harvard
pilgrim
because there were red flags that came
up and we could not conclude at the time
that a violation had taken place those
monitoring periods are have currently
been extended another year
so they're still ongoing
the formal market conduct exam process
is lengthy confidential and resource
intensive this is not always ideal for
transparency
effective use of resources
and other issues the legislation
clarifies that the parity compliance
work
can take place in tandem with the new
federal government requirements more
efficiently
the mental health parity requirements
are frequently misunderstood
mental health preparations are found in
federal law and essentially require that
the financial requirements and treatment
limitations applicable to mental health
or substance use disorder benefits are
no more restrictive than those
applicable to medical surgical benefits
ap is applicable to all health plans
about the individual and group markets
and does not mandate benefits only
parity of the benefits offered
however the aca does set minimum
benefits for mental health by including
and substance abuse treatment as it is
an essential health benefit
so the consolidated appropriations act
of 2021 amended mapia to add new federal
reporting requirements that carriers are
expected to comply with
so for each
nqtl which is a non-quantitative
treatment limit imposed the insurer must
prepare a comparative analysis that
includes that minimum a clear
description of the nqtl identification
of applicable plan terms and policies
identification of the specific mental
health substance use
disorder and med surg benefits to which
it applies identify any factors evidence
standard sources
strategies used and considered in the
design and application and then detailed
analysis demonstrating that the nqtls
applied as written in an operation
are comparable for mental health and
the med surg benefits so what we would
like to do is instead of having to do
frequent mental parity examinations we
would like to take this report and be
able to analyze this
um
along with the department of labor who
is also going to be doing this analysis
and as well as cms
and we envision this information
becoming public and it aligns our
efforts to streamline the reporting
obligations on the carrier and
strengthen the ability of the nhid and
the federal government to identify
violations consistently
this would be a major step forward in
ensuring mental health parity coverage
requirements are met second the section
removes what looks like a permitted cap
on autism treatment
this provision would most certainly be
preempted by federal laws and it's not
cleared
but that's not clear to the readers of
the statute so we're requesting to
remove it to avoid any confusion
and then finally we would like to change
shall to may
the nhid does not believe that
rules are necessary and that's why none
have been promulgated but in a recent
lba audited it was identified as a
deficiency that we did not have rules
if the federal guidelines were to
disappear then we would be in a position
to promulgate rules
so we asked that you act upon this
legislation
i'm happy to take any questions
great representative greeson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your testimony in other legislation we
use the words
shall adopt rules as necessary
and that seemed to pacify objections
it's a shall but only as necessary so
you change from shall to may which that
always opens a can of worms would it be
amenable to
if if we were to change back to shall
but then put it as necessary because you
just said that it's possible that
federal rules could change and then it
may become necessary so what if we
amended this to say shall
as may be necessary
that would be fine okay i know it's nit
noid but we did it in another piece of
legislation so i just want to see if
we'd be consistent yeah we just want to
make sure that we're not being forced to
promulgate rules when they're not
necessary
okay
any other questions
no okay representative herbert
um if you could
go through the explanation for uh on
the rule you ruled out section three
part two section three
in order to
put on put in a cap or
for this particular type of uh
um
autism i'm i i'm a little confused as to
what that the
what you intend to do by taking that out
so this um autism provision
and originally when the statute was
passed it was pre-aca
so there were treatment limitations put
in there once the aca was passed
aca federal law would likely preempt any
of these treatment limitations and but
they're still in our statute and it can
cause some confusion because
people will look at it and think that
you can have treatment limitations when
really federal law would prohibit you
from doing that so we're just trying to
clean up the statute to make clear that
you cannot have treatment limitations on
autism okay i understand that thank you
representative abel
yes thank you um
are there other
developmental disorders
besides autism that have
um
have
caps on them
um or is autism the only one i just
wondered if i wondered if it needs to be
broader than
just one
particular
this particular statute here is specific
to autism
i see so we don't have but do we have do
we have
do we
i'm
i wonder if you could let us know later
or something if there are others
uh that we might have to come back and
address in the future
so that if if that's the case we could
do it all now
so um this is a health insurance mandate
that didn't get passed while i was here
and
i was
and uh
the limitations were put in because what
this was this was a mandate that
insurance companies have to reimburse
the school district
and so at that time to make it
seemed less of a minimize the mandate
that that
these dollar amounts were put in
so yes this is the only only
mental
disability men health insurance mandate
that we have and and yes it would be the
only one with all the limits and the
reason i say that is that because
there's plenty of other statutes that
have dollar limits like hearing aids
have adult limit
medical durable goods have a
dollar amount limitations so there are
plenty of other you know limitations but
in this case this was related to just
this
uh mandate and it was uh and that was
what was passed here in new hampshire
yes and in the mental health statute the
chapter
417 e this is the only one that has
those limits but in other statutes for
other mandates there could be
okay
thank you very oh representative pilo
thank you mr chair my question is um did
you ask for this bill to be
brought forward
um
my question is um on the very first
change i see that a sentence was removed
that says such examination and
evaluation shall include provider
reimbursement practices is there a
reason why that was stricken
so provider reimbursement practices are
one
nqtl but there are many others we didn't
want to be limited to looking just at
provider reimbursements we didn't want
to imply that that's the only nqtl we
would be looking at
but the mental parity exam we just
completed was specific to provider
reimbursement
yes for the question we inquire uh um
i think it's really important that that
stays there because that's been
something we've addressed in in other
other discussions on other
things i would hate to think that we
would go through this and not provide
that information
and i think without it being in statute
it could
could be passed by so
um
there are other sections of rsa 417 e1
that do include specific requirements
for provider reimbursement okay so
amending this particular section i don't
think is going to cause that problem but
we can look at amending language if
necessary
thank you
okay okay thank you
all right does anybody else would like
to testify on 373
uh
i have a jake berry from new futures in
support of the bell
and we have the blue sheets that turned
white
okay
so 373 had six people in support and no
none a post
and with that i will close the public
hearing for 373.
yep
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee i promise this will be my
third and final bad for senator bradley
we expect senator soucy to come over for
the next bill
my name is grant bosse from the new
hampshire senate here to introduce
senate bill 385 fn on behalf of senator
jeb bradley its prime sponsor
this bill was filed at the request of
the banking industry to help combat the
financial exploitation of senior
citizens
and other vulnerable individuals
financial exploitation can be very hard
to detect but even if
a local bank suspects that something is
wrong that somebody is being taken
advantage of they lack the authority to
do anything about it to notify anybody
that they think one of their customers
is uh being taken advantage of
if passed this bill would give financial
institutions the ability to place a
short-term hold on the disbursement of
funds if they thought exploited activity
had occurred in committee senators
worked with the banking department hhs
the ag's office the banking industry to
address some technical concerns and
deliver a bill that they think is
ready for your consideration
in committee this received the support
of 54 people
for it none against
nobody opposed the bill
throughout the process it was just a
matter of
sanding and polishing to get it into the
shape it is now i would defer questions
to the industry and to the departments i
would add that there was an amendment
adding a reporting requirement asking
those departments to report to you to
the senate to the governor how many of
these exploitation reports have taken
place and what steps if any they
recommend to
further prevent financial exploitation
in the state of new hampshire uh thank
you for your consideration we ask for
your support of senate bill 385
great thank you
any questions for brent
thank you very much
okay so uh
brad
kelly's on cool cool
absolutely chrissy i was well that was
kind of pausing i said which would i
have
his uh his lobbyist his association or
him first but we always had to do
constituents first so that's why we were
can invite him up first but but yes
since you both are affiliated with the
same
institutions
good afternoon thank you mr chair
honorable members of the house commerce
and consumer affairs committee my name
is christy merrill i'm president of the
new hampshire bankers association
and with me today i also have brad
culaks and brad is a vice president i'm
sorry regional vice president of retail
banking for merrimack county savings
bank here in concord
and he's going to talk about some of his
direct experiences with financial
exploitation and how this bill can help
our association represents 38 member
banks who employ roughly 6 000 employees
in new hampshire and we're here today in
strong support of the bill
this legislation is very closely modeled
after a bill that was filed in 2019
senate bill 252
and that legislation enabled broker
dealers to delay disbursement of funds
if they suspected financial exploitation
that bill had broad support and was
signed into law by governor sununu
this legislation would allow a bank to
delay disbursement of funds from an
account of an eligible adult or an
account from a beneficiary if they if
they suspects if they suspect financial
exploitation is occurring
the bank would have to provide written
notice to the department of health and
human services and they would copy the
banking department on that notice not
more than two days after the delay has
taken place
the bill defines an eligible adult as
someone who is 65 years of age or older
or 18 years of
age or older who is vulnerable and the
the term vulnerable is defined in
statute
which i have in my testimony that
hopefully you have a copy of
um
and i also just want to point out that
under
rsa 161f
banks already notify health and human
services when financial exploitation is
suspected
and this would require an additional
written notice if there is a delay
in the disbursement of funds
and so i'm happy to answer any questions
but i do want to let brad take a few
moments and share what he some of his
experiences
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the committee um as miss merrill stated
my name is brad coulax i'm the regional
vice president retail banking for
merrimack county savings bank
and i'm here in support of sb 385. um i
have more than 10 years of retail
banking experience and i have seen
prevented or attempted to prevent
multiple occurrences of financial
exploitation
imagine yourselves sitting in the living
room
of an elderly customer
asking questions of their finances and
how it has come to be that they are
writing their grandson checks that
appear to be altered but yet ultimately
approved by them
seeing a father
take what we feel is advantage of their
vulnerable 20-something son
having him withdraw money from his
savings account leaving pennies
and giving that money to his dad
and watching a mother who feels bad for
her son that has found himself in legal
trouble
draining her life savings just to
support him
i have done this multiple times
it is heartbreaking and frustrating to
have to explain to someone that their
loved ones
appear to be taking advantage of them
through coercion or altering of checks
we report these suspicious these
suspicions to the state in hopes that
the situation can be investigated in
timely manner but ultimately
the timing is a matter of perspective
when your life savings is walking out
the door timely means now
this bill would give us the power to
delay the release of those funds giving
dhhs in the state time to investigate
our observations
exploitation extends beyond loved ones
there are countless number of scams in
society preying on the vulnerable a
common one is a grandparent receiving a
call that their grandchild is in jail
and that they need to be bailed out
through knowledge gained by social media
the scammer is able to convince the
grandparent of the story
the scammer then requests a wire to be
sent typically in the thousands of
dollars once the wire is sent the money
is gone
and rarely recovered
in one instance we had a customer
approach us for such a wire
we asked many questions as our staff is
trained to do so
we advise the customer of the known scam
in the area
the customer insisted they spoke with
their grandson
absolutely certain it was their grandson
and the money was sent
a couple hours later
he returned to the bank realizing it was
a scam
unfortunately it was too late the money
was gone
yes as bankers our role is to facilitate
the movement of money
but as community bankers and stewards of
our communities i feel we have an
obligation to protect our most
vulnerable vulnerable population from
financial exploitation sb 385 adds a
tool which helps us accomplish that
i would much rather apologize to a
customer for delaying the release of
funds
than to explain to them
why we let the situation just occur
i thank you for your support
i also have a copy of my testimony
okay
are you a co-sponsor
i realized
but i'm way at the bottom of the list
when i was looking through this
i did not see anything about
a trust account
where the two
major trustees are over 65
but the
the sons grandsons granddaughters are
also part of the trust does this address
anything about the
the trust
thank you
thank you for co-sponsoring the
legislation um
regarding your question we have not had
any specific discussions about the trust
i don't believe the bill specifically
addresses trusts i would have to go back
representative and just double check to
make sure
it may be included in this but we have
not had specific discussions about
trusts but
the intent is really to try to address
any disbursement that a bank may hold
but i i just want to get back to you on
your question if that's okay
representative johnson
thank you for taking my question and i i
can empathize with this bill we had an
issue with my mother-in-law
so i can understand it but you had
mentioned that reporting it to dhhs
what about
um reporting it to somebody else that's
on the account like my mother-in-law had
my sister-in-law on the account but they
weren't contacting my sister-in-law to
let her know
um would that be a better step than
immediately going to dhhs with it
looking to see who else was on the
accounts
yes thank you representative johnson for
your comment for your question um we
have had a lot of conversations with the
banking department and health and human
services and the attorney general's
office who believe they're all
represented today we've had very good
conversations about that but we've had
discussions about the right way to do
that
the process in hhs is existing today and
it's been around for quite some time
there are folks here that could probably
speak to that process a little bit
better and how that came about and if
that should be different we did explore
different
avenues of going about that but
knowing we really tried to very closely
mirror this off of the existing
securities language and so we that
that's why we have the process that we
have today um but i don't know brad do
you want to speak to that in terms of
notifying people before hhs in in i i
can
speak from our perspective at the
merrimack that yes there have been
occasions where we do reach out to uh
joint account holders um
to make sure or powers of attorneys to
to make them aware because that's the
right thing to do and and to help
protect so um you know obviously our
first reaction is not to jump right to
hhs and and share the information
but is to identify and educate and and
hopefully resolve it um but as we see
patterns grow
and then we get a feeling of the level
of exploitation is where we begin to
escalate that
um and then share the information with
the state in hopes they get the support
to take care of our customer
for the question being claire
so you so most banks
and i i think my local bank also did the
same
you're first in incline is to reach out
to other people that may be on the
account
as long as they're not the ones you're
questioning but
you're going to reach out to them before
you start going or calling dhhs and
that's kind of your standard practice i
would say just as a common courtesy as a
common courtesy when we can identify
that corrects
and i would like to add to um
representative we've heard from our
other uh banking members too who have
said that it's not this is not something
that happens right away they observe the
patterns and it's after they see
repeated patterns that's been happening
for a while um and that's when they they
start to reach out to other members on
the account and to reach out to health
and human services but um they do
observe the patterns for a while it's uh
it's not it's something that they don't
just react very quickly on
did you ever
okay
representative mclaren thank you um just
a question it seems to me that this
could be a little bit tricky trying to
make a decision
are there cases where
the bank has uh has proceeded with a
sending a check out that in fact it
bounces back on you and you've been held
liable
in other words you maybe made a mistake
you want to take that or
um
what i can tell you is um there there is
there is language in the legislation to
try to address immunity um uh
they're trying to protect bankers that
are looking at all the evidence in front
of them and trying to make the best
decision that they can and do so
cautiously um and so we have included
that language here but brad do you want
to speak about how that sort of
practically plays out yeah i think that
there there are definitely occasions
where things may slip through the cracks
um and then it it boils back to
depending upon the level of fraud
or exploitation where
the bank does take the loss
on an item that is paid
to make the customer whole
so
thank you very much
representative herbert
um is there a system in well first of
all uh who do you call first
in other words if you have a problem you
you think you have a problem
who is it that you call
um so
it's a great question so my staff as
they're trained when they i identify
what they believe are observed to be
behaviors that are signs of exploitation
uh actually reach out to me um and run
the scenario through through me um and
from there we have an internal risk
department that i begin to engage at
that point
bring them up to speed the details of
the situation
what is what's going on
and then the ultimate
reaching out to the state if necessary
is done through our harvest department
that may vary from from bank to bank
for the question is it the attorney
general's office
consumer protection that you would call
um after brad's he mentioned that you
know they his their process internally
at the merrimack county savings bank
once
family members have been contacted and
once you've talked to the customer and
the issue is still there it would go the
way that the process exists today in rsa
161 f as it goes to health and human
services and health and human services
at that point there is a law enforcement
component that gets to the attorney
general's office
but i can't speak to how that works but
it does get to them at some level but
hhs works with them after the bank has
communicated with health and human
services in the first instance
really question main choir so is there a
system whereby you can flag an account
and and the other
enforcement agencies are notified
because if speed is of the essence i
would think that you would want
everybody to know you've got your eye on
something
there there are measures in place for us
to put alerts on accounts
if we feel
a
potential transactions need to be viewed
more closely
um
and then from there it's we typically
would direct if reports have already
been filed internally
additional items or observations at that
point at least for us
are pushed to that appropriate
department internally
thank you
okay see no more questions thank you
very much
thank you
uh okay lauren
warner from the new hampshire banking
department
takes no position
good afternoon honorable chair and
members of the committee i'm lauren
warner the deputy general counsel for
the banking department uh just wanted to
briefly note that the department is
comfortable with the language of this
bill and worked with
oh sorry
worked with the bankers association um
and drafting the amended version um
certainly can answer any questions you
might have of the banking department but
just wanted to briefly
state that for the record
uh representative greeson that's the
question
thank you mr chair and thank you again
for for testifying uh and and i saved my
question for the banking department
because you may have a little more
familiarity with it
uh this is a new section that this list
is new section and i want to make sure
that uh somewhere if it because it's not
stated in here
in this new section but somewhere in rsa
um that where there is an opportunity
we know who is manipulating
the adult or the person with the with
the money in there too
a family member whomever um is there
something in statute now that
provides for the restitution of those
funds that have been taken plus any
penalties and stuff to make that person
whole again understanding the phone
scams we can't really do much about but
when we actually know who the
perpetrator is is that anywhere in
statute because i know it's not in here
it's not within our banking laws so our
jurisdiction in this case would be over
the financial institutions sadly not
over the bad actors but that is where
the attorney general's
um office comes into play under the
consumer protection act as well as and i
know there's a representative here from
the attorney general's office who can
speak further but in these instances
where we have seen this we've referred
this on immediately to the ag's office
good thank you
uh representative fargo
um when i'm reading the fiscal note
thank you for your testimony and when
i'm reading the fiscal note um
i guess the banking department had
weighed in on this and they would need
two additional staff to support this so
um that was with the prior version of
the original version of the bell had um
the banking department instead of being
copied on it more so regularly involved
in
actually the determination of whether or
not uh disbursement should um time frame
should extend the hold should extend and
we felt in that case if we were going to
be as intricately involved in
those investigations we would require
additional staff but with the amended
version it removes that so that we are
copied and notified and kept
in lieu of everything going on in the
process but would not require additional
staff there is the possibility
further consumer complaints could come
into our office whether from the actual
individual who owns the account or the
person who
is trying to receive the funds
but we believe at that time this time
our resources would be able to manage
that and we have the help of the dhhs
would be they can answer questions
further involvement to their
investigation along with the ag's office
okay so you don't anticipate any
additional cost because i know you're
self-funded so it would mean that you'd
have to try to recoup that car yeah
you're saying at this point there
wouldn't be any at this point with the
new this amended version of the bill we
do not
proceed okay
richard said you have a question you're
also no i don't get it
all right
see then thank you very much thank you
uh brian townsend from the attorney
general's office
good afternoon my name is brian townsend
i'm an assistant attorney general with
the new hampshire department of justice
and i am the prosecutor
and i am the prosecutor for the elder
abuse and financial exploitation unit
the the attorney general's office here
is here uh today to speak in support of
senate bill 385.
um
my unit investigates and pros prosecutes
cases of financial abuse
assault and neglect of the elderly
throughout the state
over my three years as a prosecutor in
the unit
we've worked closely with the department
of health and human services
the bureau of elderly and adult services
we receive referrals from them that stem
from the mandatory reporting laws
we investigate investigate those cases
and prosecute those cases
what we also do is we also
counsel
and educate individuals throughout this
state and
attempt to prev protect them from scams
um scams are running rampant
especially in covid times and there's
only so much we can do
so with this bill
uh it would give the banks
the opportunity to step in uh and
protect the elderly throughout this
state
um often we see individuals only after
the money is gone long gone
and there's nothing we can do about it
with the exception of course ordering
restitution if there's someone that we
can prosecute and even then they don't
have the funds to repay it
and so
we've investigated and prosecuted cases
of grandparent scams and the one thing
that we hear from victims in those cases
is that they wish
uh the banks could have done a little
bit more
as well as they have done
they're limited they can only ask so
many questions they can't actually stop
the transaction
and so this would give them that ability
and so in that respect we uh we fully
support the bill
i'd be happy to address any questions
oh rob zaman
thank you mr chair
and thank you for testifying
um and i understand this is a
significant issue that uh as people get
up in years they need maybe a little bit
of oversight over their their decision
making
what um
what would happen if there was say a
false positive that that um
so so the inverse of that someone is
fully corpus mentis they have
their decision-making ability but
something about the transaction
triggers the bank to step in and stop a
valid transaction
maybe it's a mortgage payment maybe it's
some some important transaction
what would be the recourse for that
person
to uh you know
be personally restituted if
if the bank stepped in when it shouldn't
have how would that process work
i'm not exactly sure how that process
would work this certainly provides
immunity for uh the banks if they are
making those decisions in good faith so
there would have to be a good faith um
reason why the bank was withholding uh
the payment
so so in that case they would they would
be immune as my understanding um but if
there was some sort of bad faith and
they withheld the payment without
sufficient evidence uh then there they
could be liable as my understanding um
for repayment
uh they are they are tasked with
investigating whether there is uh
financial exploitation uh swiftly under
the bill um and so perhaps they could
call the mortgage company that wouldn't
take very long at all um and that could
be settled very quickly so i think it
would be uh the extremely rare case
where where you're hypothetical uh came
to be
i'm just going to take liberty for a
follow-up um sure
so this would protect the banks from
liability um
and so
the term good faith is a very loaded
term how who determines what is good
faith and uh
a lot of people have automated uh
payments that they don't really pay
attention to because it's monthly
automated and you might not find out
right away that a payment was missed
but uh to the question of good faith who
determines that i can just speak
generally um about good faith um you
know in the court systems um but
theoretically it would be uh it would be
a court that would that would make a
determination as to whether there's uh
good faith or not good faith any sort of
uh liability for payment would be my
understanding again um that's just sort
of
my understanding of the way that would
operate
any other questions
thank you mr townsend for your testimony
thank you
let's see
see
kathy harvard
so good afternoon to the chair and the
members of the committee my name is
kathy harvard i'm from hanover
i'm here speaking in my own capacity as
a long-time alzheimer's advocate and a
long-time volunteer with the alzheimer's
association
and i thank you very much for allowing
me to testify today in support of senate
bill 385
relative to financial exploitation of
vulnerable adults and most specifically
how that pertains to those battling
demand alzheimer's and other dementias
so today i'm actually the voice of more
than 26 thousand people here in the
granite state who are suffering from
some form of dementia
and they're 57 000 caregivers this is
just new hampshire
i'm also these are the people who care
for them every single day
who manage their lives as the disease
progresses
and i do this because i'm honoring my
husband i was a caregiver myself for
more than 10 years and so all of us i
think feel that
this bill
would help provide a guard rail
additional protection for our families
to safeguard
our very most vulnerable family members
from exploitation
most of you are aware that alzheimer's
begins rather silently like a thief in
the night it's very very slowly and
quietly steals away a person's cognitive
abilities
and their ultimately their ability to
live independently
it's notoriously difficult to diagnose
for everybody for the doctors for family
members and family members are very
frequently not even aware that their
loved one is having difficulty managing
some of the most basic elements of
independent living
until a problem arises and then it's too
late
in a rapidly aging state like ours where
many seniors are already living alone
and families far away it's clear that we
need to provide some sort of mechanisms
to safeguard our most vulnerable and
certainly that at the top of that list
would certainly be those suffering from
alzheimer's and other dementia
alzheimer's is a progressive always
fatal neurodegenerative disease that
causes a gradual decline in memory
thinking and reasoning skills in the
early stages we might see memory loss
that interferes with daily living maybe
difficulty completing familiar tasks
and decreased judgment
alzheimer's
symptoms only get worse over time and it
impairs judgment
and often puts individuals at very real
risk for rejecting help and making poor
decisions
cognitive decline associated with
alzheimer's frequently leads to
difficulty in managing personal finances
sadly forgetting to pay bills bouncing
checks large and unexplained decreases
in a bank balance these are often one of
the very first ways that families even
become aware of the severity of their
loved one's cognitive decline
so this puts people with alzheimer's or
another form of dementia at greater risk
for financial exploitation or fraud
financial exploitation typically occurs
through theft or scams are there forms
of elder exploitation
and it's because we know that their
trust has been abused different others
who are scamming them feel either
financial entitlement or the ability to
coerce those who are more vulnerable it
could come via a telephone call an
internet offer a knock on the door by a
stranger or as we've heard a little
earlier today sadly a family member
one in five older americans is has been
a victim or is a victim of financial
exploitation and in 2020 older adults
across the u s
filed more than 334 thousand fraud
reports
with reported losses of 600 million
because victims of financial
exploitation are often reluctant to
report abuse
or they lack the physical or cognitive
capacity to report it or perhaps they
fear retaliation or reluctant to have
their abuser
prosecuted
or perhaps they wish to avoid potential
embarrassment
a lot of fraud is never even reported so
these numbers are really only a fraction
of what and the extent of harm that
happens to older adults in general but
even more so
those suffering from cognitive decline
through alzheimer's or another form of
dementia
by
2025 the grant number of granite staters
living with alzheimer's will have
increased from today by 23 percent
now we'll have 32 000
folks who are actively suffering from
some sort of dementia
in our state and these numbers will
continue to grow until we do find a way
to cure or prevent these dreaded
diseases
because as these numbers grow
opportunities for financial exploitation
only increase we ask your support
for this senate bill 385 to help ensure
that those who are living with cognitive
impairment in new hampshire
are safe from financial abuse
by allowing banks and other financial
institutions the ability to place a hold
on distribution of funds that they
suspect where financial exploitation may
be at risk it may be happening
we're building a guard rail we're
building a safety net to help protect
some of our communities most vulnerable
adults from a financial exploitation
thank you for your support for this
important bill
okay
oh representative mclaren has a question
uh yes uh thank you well thank you for
uh testifying today
in your experience
um let's say you have a situation where
a spouse or maybe a parent has uh
has cognitive disabilities
is there any way that a the other spouse
or a child can step in
in a less formal way than let's say a
getting a power of attorney or a court
order to to basically make sure that
everything goes through them is there a
way to do that facilitate that
well i'm i'm not i don't want to give
you a legal interpretation but i can
give you the family uh interpretation of
what happens most frequently before you
get to that point
of either
making a legal determination of someone
who will be the executor
it is an ongoing negotiation as the
person's cognitive abilities decline and
it
it is very tricky it is very tricky
indeed and so oftentimes it might be in
the medical context but it could also be
in the banking context the family member
who is if they're available who is
looking after their loved one will also
will look for the support
of somebody in that other institution to
help them manage their loved ones
medical care or their financial care and
so any kind of safeguards that can help
them do that will be appreciated because
it's a very long road it's a very long
disease the average time could be 10 12
years
and there are many years where we're
simply seeing impaired judgment
before we get to that point of making
legal change
so safeguards that can help
put on a break before a disaster happens
even in the early stages it's a really
good idea
uh
ribs and burrows thank you i'll be brief
and this is a would you believe my
mother had alzheimer's and it was
similar scenarios that you described
my mother who's incredibly bright woman
hired a caretaker who approached her in
the parking lot of a hospital which she
would never ever have done
had she not been her mind been failing
with no references this woman stole
money
computers um jewelry
and
we found out that my mother wasn't
paying bills only because my brother
went through it and so because we had
these signs my brother was able to
convince my parents that that he should
have power of attorney but i think one
of the problems is people who don't have
actively involved children
or who don't have children um so i just
wanted to share that because that
concerns me
thank you that's exactly right
thank you very much
okay one card left and john you get to
wrap it up
and rachel lincoln john williams
chairman hunt and members of the house
commerce and consumer affairs committee
for the record my name is john williams
i'm the director of legislative affairs
and i have to say the one thing i'm very
remiss is it's taken me this long to
come before your committee and it
happened to happen after crossover on
this very important bill with me today
good good afternoon everyone i'm rachel
laken and i am the administrator for the
adult protection program that is housed
with the department of health and human
services
this is a collaborative effort we have
to thank in direct appreciation to ms
merrill over with the new hampshire
bankers association she worked very
collaboratively in the way to do best
legislation to reach out to state
agencies
the banking department the department of
justice and our agency to really perfect
the legislation that's before you
this has been road tested as ms merrill
had mentioned because this uh a similar
bill uh that this is basically
the architecture you'll see is senate
bill 252 and that was relative to also
financial exploitation of the elderly
and it provided the same type of
framework as it relates to financial
advisors um and it was brought at the
request in 2019 and enacted in law in
the same year by the secretary of
state's office through their bureau of
securities so this bill that you see
before you we strongly support we think
it advances the goals of protecting the
vulnerable citizens that uh miss uh
lincoln and her group at our adult
protective services support and we're
here to answer any questions from the
committee
okay
any questions for dhss this is it
all right so i have no more cards and
assuming nobody else wants to testify
i have from the midnight
filing they have 19 support no
no one opposed
and
on the sign in sheet i have kyle baker
from the cooperative credit union
association support with that
close to public hearing
okay
yeah
senator cc
okay
i will
open up the hearing on senate bill 210.
um one of the great things uh or
was great but
this opportunity where we're in this big
committee room and we're sharing our
committee rooms that
is that uh
tuesdays
where commerce house commerce committee
does not meet
and so therefore i have an opportunity
to watch
the senate conference committee
and uh much relieved to see that this
bill has been fixed
so that we do not have the huge turnout
that the senate was very fortunate to
have
so and i will introduce senator susie
from manchester who will introduce the
bill
to us
good afternoon senator good
afternoon mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i'm donna soucy
i represent senate district 18 comprised
of the town of litchfield and five wards
in the city of manchester
i'm here on behalf of senator bradley
and myself as a co-sponsor senator
bradley sends his apologies
but really i worked quite a bit with
senator bradley on this legislation
particularly in crafting the amendment
which replaced the bill
and i think we have reached what is a
good compromise and i'm happy to present
that here
for you today
first senator bradley um wanted you to
know that it was conversations with many
people that reside in manufactured
housing parks that led him to sponsor
this bill um in particular mrs louise
ride out who you're going to hear from i
believe in just a bit
and some of the concerns expressed led
to the original filing of the bill
after that lengthy hearing that you
watched mr chairman senator bradley and
i had an opportunity to sit down on
several occasions
with tara reardon from the community
loan fund who i believe you will hear
from and karen soucy from the new
hampshire manufactured housing
association to work through some of the
issues that had been identified and
presented to us and to try to negotiate
the compromise that is here before you
today
so i'll just walk you through what the
bill does
the bill's primary purpose
was to encourage greater participation
by residents of a park contemplating
acquisition and becoming a resident
owned community often called a rock
so the first section of the bill if you
look on the first page
you'll see in bold several references to
notice being made not only to the new
hampshire housing finance authority but
also to the new hampshire manufactured
housing association
that notice is um
limited in scope it's merely um
it would exclude price terms and
conditions of the offer but it is merely
a notice
if you turn to the second page um that's
where pretty much uh the heart of the
legislation is starting on line three
the bill provides for
um
greater notice
to
the tenants
currently residing within the park so it
requires either a certified letter or we
recognized that there were significant
costs to that and that might not
be sustainable or a verified
hand-delivered letter and the
verification process we weren't specific
on we believed that it could likely be
a photograph taken with a cell phone
upon delivery of the letter that letter
would include the mortgage terms the
land rent per homeowner and other costs
or fees that would be associated with it
but the most important part begins on
line six where it says such letters
shall include a form to request an
absentee vote for or against the
purchase of the park
one of the concerns that we were
attempting to address was that
in some instances and i know there are
statistics available i'm not going to go
through all of them but in some
instances you had a very very very small
percentage of residents actually
participating in the vote to become a
resident owned community
and it was our feeling that
such an acquisition and such a
substantial decision
should
be made by a larger group of residents
now once again it's like elections we
all stand for election some voters
choose to exercise their rights some do
not the same will be true here
but we wanted the absentee process in
place to ensure that there weren't
obstacles to people being able to go to
vote whether it was
child care or
not wanting to be within the group on
many of these facilities do not have
actual facilities on premises within the
park where a meeting can take place
there are costs associated with them
leasing space so we felt it important
that we at the very least attempt to
make the process
as open as possible and to inform
residents as much as possible
the other thing that we did beginning on
line seven was to ensure that in order
to cast the vote members residents have
to become part of the association
want to ensure that those association
fees are no more than five dollars
and the reason for that is that we want
the residents to have buy-in and you'll
hear testimony about
the reason for that to become part of
the cooperative but also we didn't want
the fee to be so high that it once again
would preclude someone from being able
to cast their vote
in addition
we wanted to ensure that there was a
mechanism for
fair process open process of counting
the votes
and then beginning on line 14
one of the issues and once again it was
only one park that was cited i can't
tell you there are any others but in one
instance there was a resident community
where
those
tenant those residents who were not part
of the association had to pay an
additional 200
a month in rental fees
and given that we view manufactured
housing as potentially another form of
affordable housing the concern was that
there needed to be some restraint on how
much you could charge therefore on lines
14 and 15 you see uh the language
limiting it to
no more than 25 if there's going to be
that distinction once again that's a
determination made by the residents it's
a form of their self-governance but it
was something that had been
been raised and we thought needed to be
addressed
the last part
that you will see beginning on line 18
put
the language that i mentioned about the
five dollar fee
into
the
corporation statutes so that it's in two
places so if somebody is going to look
to form such a cooperative they might
not go directly to the manufactured
housing legislation but if they're going
to form a cooperative specific
to a manufactured housing park that
language is there as well so that it's
illustrated that they cannot charge more
than the five dollars as i said uh
senator bradley and i spent a lot of
time we had a lot of good meetings with
ms reardon who's here and mrs soucy
and we continued to hear from a number
of residents throughout this process
so this was this was our attempt at a
compromise i think it's a reasonable
compromise i think it puts in place
some very good guard rails for the
process it encourages greater
participation
and i hope that for those folks that
choose
to
become resident owned communities and
engage in self-governance
it's a better way for them to start and
it's a good way to
provide additional affordable housing in
our state so with that um i would
conclude my testimony i'd be happy to
answer any questions as i said i know
there are others that will follow me
that will give you more detail about
acquisition and the process and also
tell you about specific issues they've
encountered so thank you mr chairman
thank you we do have a question
representative johnson
thank you for taking my question
um
would this impact any of the current
as you call them rock or communities to
make them follow these rules now or
would they be grandfathered to do what
they're doing now
i guess
you know how would we handle
before and now
so any existing community that is
already a residentially owned community
would have already cast their vote
they'd have their association fee
the
rental portion would apply to those
and i think you'll be hearing another
bill
that senator bradley also sponsored
requiring additional resolution
processes for those tenants that reside
in the resident owned communities so
those that have already formed resident
owned communities would not have that
significant impact by this legislation
but new resident owned communities going
forward
representative abel
yes thank you thank you senator um
you you are very clear and very helpful
i i do have uh one question
um
the
bill the amended bill that we have in
front of us
does
mention
sale of
of a manufactured housing park
would this also apply if the owner
wanted to sell to someone other than the
residents or
could you please address that so when
the
owner intends to sell the residents are
given an opportunity
to
acquire the park there's there's a whole
scheme within the statute already for
how they go about acquiring the park and
it's typically the community loan fund
that would assist them in that process
and there are certain time frames and
benchmarks to do so
if i may just
mr chairman just along those lines i
neglected to add one thing um regarding
this
when the vote is cast to become a
resident owned community it is a simple
majority of those participating in
person and the absentee ballots i know
there was a concern previously that
there were certain thresholds and that
that would preclude any new resident
owned communities this legislation does
not include that it's simply a majority
of those participating
okay we're all set thank you thank you
very much mr chairman good to see you
two days in a row
okay karen susie from the new hampshire
manufactured housing authority
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee
my name is karen soucy and i am here on
behalf of the new hampshire manufactured
housing association um mostly i think
i'm here just to answer questions that
you may have
by chance no okay
[Laughter]
the intent really is to create more
transparency remove
barriers from voting and certainly
increase voter participation
i guess i can sort of follow up on what
senator susie mentioned earlier with
regard to a small number of residents
participating have some
minutes that i'd like to hand out to you
if you don't mind
so while that's being distributed
the documents are meeting minutes for
bearview crossing cooperative that's a
cooperative located in allenstown new
hampshire
that is a community that consists of
i believe 300
housing units
according to these meeting minutes from
march 6 of 2019
on the second page which is highlighted
there's a question how many people do
you need to buy the park
according to the pre-acquisition bylaws
the quorum needed is one-third of the
total membership
okay and it resulted in the fact that if
only 27 members
um
were present for the majority to vote
yes excuse me the majority would be 14.
so 14 people
could commit a 300 housing unit
community
to move forward with a 20 million dollar
purchase
i just wanted to bring that to your
attention so that is why we are moving
forward with this bill this is why the
association has worked collaboratively
with the residents um that i believe are
scheduled to testify here today
do you have any questions
mr chair
representative yes thank you for uh your
testimony for this information um just
this would be an easy one i i think
uh you mentioned there are approximately
300 housing units correct in this uh
bear view crossing cooperative and there
are 80 members
could you explain the difference between
the number of housing units being 300
and a membership of 80.
if there are only 80 uh members uh what
about the other
220 housing units are they not members
that is my understanding you are not
required to be a member
of the park
but in order to vote you are required to
be a member if that makes sense
further question may inquire do you have
any uh do you have any idea what the
membership requirements are for this
particular
crossing cooperative it's my
understanding that membership
requirements vary for each cooperative
um
[Music]
i know that this one i believe the
um
[Music]
i believe it was 300 to join
but i believe the residents excuse me
the residents will have that more
information on that
for the question
so to be a member
of the association
in the bearview crossing cooperative
one would have to pay three 300
that is my understanding
thank you
that is what the bill is addressing is
that outrageous dollar amount yeah just
to be clear okay
okay
representative mclaren uh thank you very
much uh just a quick question i i guess
i
don't quite understand that if a
minority of the people vote to to buy
the
the park
that does that obligate everybody else
to do the same thing
yes so once
the
minority of people
vote to purchase the park
all the remaining households
are committed to paying off that
mortgage just
a quick phone question
so the only way they could opt out is to
get out of the park sell their property
etc
that would be my understanding thank you
okay
all righty
thank you very much
so
louise right out and uh bonnie
galleries
good afternoon
good afternoon my name is louise rydo
thank you for hearing us today
i'm really excited that this bill is
here
we
are really happy with all the work that
senator bradley and senator susie
did for us
because
i live in bedview crossing
and we have approximately 300 household
there
it was purchased in july of 2019
and it became
that's when it became the community
unfortunately
not enough people were really informed
i think that any purchase it was 18
million dollars that was the purchase
price our loans are close to 21 million
dollars
so even if people heard 18 million
neglecting to tell us
the true loan amount
was detrimental because some people
would have said yes not knowing
the other fees that were involved in
getting that
funding
and i had to pay ten dollars to be able
to vote to be a member to vote
the membership fee there is three
hundred dollars
and we're allowed to in the beginning we
were allowed to like pay ten dollars and
five dollars a month or you could pay it
all up front now they require people who
are moving into the park to pay it all
up front
and we should all all residents should
have access to the mortgage terms and
land rent per homeowner before voting to
purchase a park
it's just a good consumer in
homeowner i mean where we want to make
the best
buy you know you don't it sounds so
threatening when your park is being sold
i moved there in october of 2018 and i
found out less than a month later that
it was going to be sold and i really had
no idea about co-ops or anything so it
was all new to me but i attended many
many meetings and i asked many many
questions which i had been
said that i do ask a lot of questions
and i was hoping that more people were
would participate
and it kind of made me not understand
why people wouldn't want to
but a lot of the people
were not informed properly and this is
great that
there is a there is a way to get to the
people
have them informed give them notices
they they need to know what they're
getting into and
if and then at that point if they choose
not to vote that's on them
but i love the fact that
i've voted my whole life and i love the
fact that the participation will
strengthen
the co-ops it will really strengthen
everybody's
because some people are afraid people
like i'm 67 people that are older than
me
they're afraid to go out of the houses
sometimes
but if you have an absentee and we were
not allowed to do absentee
any of our votes anything in the co-op
so this is exciting for people who are
able to do an absentee ballot
you know i think it's an exciting bill
and i know senator soucy and senator
bradley worked so hard
and i know they worked hard with the
community loan fund
and i think that what they're presenting
to you is amazing
i think it's a move
a forward direction for affordable
housing and let's get people more
involved and be better and
it's it's not
you know just
it's great it's a great bill and i
really appreciate the time well you
might want to add that down
and only like only two of the
22 of the paid membership and you did
ask about how many members we have now
well because our fee for non-membership
is 200 a month
people were really yeah on top of the
564 that we pay before water and sewer
that's a lot that's not even a quarter
that gets the point of not affordable
so yes so now a lot of there are a lot
of members i'm not sure the exact amount
of members but most of the people had to
join
or pay that because remember
community loan fund services low to
moderate income
so if you take
this and say oh they let us pay an extra
200 you're not really serving the people
that you're trying to serve
so we have to i think you have to look
at the whole
whole package
and now now it doesn't become what
you're trying to work with
and a lot of people are excited to get
it and be in it
there are there are issues here and
there i'm not going to say there aren't
but there are
but i i really support this bill
and we hope that you support this bill
we believe that this is a step in the
right direction in order to shed more
light on the operations in the new
hampshire community loan fund
and i'm just going to let i'm going to
pass this out
it will make sure the residents are
better informed and more involved in the
purchase of a multi-million dollar park
and
all residents should have access to the
mortgage terms
we have
four loans
only at one point were we told that one
of our loans was a balloon loan
i just found out that all of our loans
are balloon loans
and they're all due in 2029 so we have
it's an uphill battle for us
and this doesn't this bill might not
affect our co-op directly it does in a
way
but
let's go forward for the other co-ops
thank you for
listening
thank you for coming
nice to meet you yeah just move the mic
over to you so there you go
um i'm here to support this sb210 as
well
um
this bill as louise said it helps
everybody in the park now people that
are coming into a co-op
and it gives better insight on what
you're what you're putting your money
into
um
these people were told
a lot of how do i want to put this this
200 fee
most of the people in this park were
forced
to join this co-op and to to jump on the
bandwagon because the majority of the
people in our park are elderly like
myself i'm 69 you're 60 something you're
in your 70s
we all live on fixed incomes 564 a month
with 200 and now you're spending 40 or
50 on top of that
for your water and sewer
so now you're over 800 a month
my social security check is 1200 a month
that doesn't and i have a mortgage
so this gives better insight again
so the people that
people that want to participate and have
this co-op they know what they're
getting into
they'll look at the bill and they'll say
well not three years later oh my god we
have three balloon loans
nothing was was brought forward that was
truthful to the people in this co-op
it was everything was unslid under the
rug
our park is in default it's been a
non-monetary default for six months
but again getting back to this this bill
it would do a world of good for
everybody in our co-ops now people that
want to go and do a co-op
they have more insight they'll know what
they're getting into
and we would appreciate anything you do
again i have to thank senator susie
senator bradley for spending the time
with the three of us listening to
listening to what we had to give them
the insight we gave them and for the all
the hard work they did to put this bill
forward
and i'm going to cry
we do have a question representative
terry
thank you i'm in complete agreement uh
with where you want to go with this um
with the bill um but for some strange
reason i just want to have a better
understanding of how bad things are
so
um
did you have to pay in order to become a
resident
at this location
have a unit in the bare view crossing
cooperative
if you buy a house now you have to pay
300 to join the co-op okay and then you
have to pay 200
more every month after you pay the
okay if you don't pay the 300 and you
don't want to be
to to be able to vote we had to pay
so there were a lot of people that
didn't pay and weren't didn't vote
so that's why the low turnout and that's
why the numbers are so low but at this
point if
you don't
you you choose not to be a member
then you do pay the 200.
why don't you start by first telling us
how much was the rent before any of this
thing
occurred when i moved in the rent
i heinz corporation owned it
the rent was 541 a month
541 a month and then what happened was
before because we had a investor rhp
that wanted to buy
so we were told that
heinz raised the rents of 559
and then after we voted for the co-op
i do not know why our
we raised the rent another five dollars
so in the course of between january 2019
and july of 2019
our rent went up with 20 something
dollars
now you have to pay
for the mortgage
that would have been
to who knows what the rent would have
been once this new heinz corporation
well heinz owned it so heinz you know it
would it's not hard to sell it they
wanted to sell so a lot of people were
afraid of an investor like our hp coming
in and charging an extra 200 a month
for our lot fee for who knows it's an
unknown you don't know it was an unknown
it's an unknown one
but so at this point the
members of the community you know a
handful
got together and said let's go to
the you know to
the community loan fund and put this
package together and the problem is that
there was a limited amount of people who
were showing up that initial vote
to make that decision
so follow please further questions so
um in addition to the fact that you
mentioned that there was not very good
information
prior to the meeting i wonder would you
believe okay that's would you believe
of course not
um
did you mention something about a ten
dollar
fee
to vote so in addition to all the other
fees and rents and everything else that
you're paying
uh even if you were up to date with all
of these payments and fees
you had to pay ten dollars just for the
privilege to vote
this is not free for thank you very much
mr chair this sounds like a poll tax to
me
this i thought that was illegal or is
that only in the south
this is outrageous thank you okay would
you believe yes i represented
thank you mr chairman thank you ladies
for for testifying i'm still trying to
wrap my head around all of this as well
who is responsible for paying this 18 21
million dollar mortgage that you own
and how where's that money coming from
to make that payment because you now
you've said that the park is actually
it's in a non-monetary default
yeah okay
so
who who's responsible for paying that
where's that money coming from because
it takes 300 to
join
plus
200 a month
to be a member
no
it's a 300 membership fee to join to
join but some people don't even have to
right no if you do not join
your option is to pay 200 extra dollars
a month as a non-member got it okay
and
the money comes from
all of us and
then it's extra to vote
it was extra to vote but our payments
for these loans which are
one loan is
almost five percent the other one's a
little bit less those loans every loan
payment and we're only paying interest
as you know with balloon loans
that comes from a lot rent of 564 a
month
so it's coming from us we don't well
right yeah as it should but right right
right this is our responsibility so it's
either it's either
three hundred dollars to join the
association your lot rents 584
or you don't join the association and
your lot rent is 784 764 764 excuse me
764. and they need to pay for the
privilege of voting
okay
i think i understand
and i am exhausted
okay you're excited we are too
i
represent fargo
thank you and and
i'm sorry if you had to go through this
is some kind of appalling to me and
but i'm
i'm i must not be understanding properly
what happens to those people who were
living there who didn't want to didn't
want to be a part of it like
maybe they didn't vote or they voted no
um what happened to them i mean dude
are they still held
you sure yeah um what happened to the
people that didn't vote and didn't want
the co-op what they ended up doing was
they were they paid their money to to
vote
and then they when they were told that
they had to pay 200 extra a month on top
of their lot fee if they didn't join the
co-op then they opted to to to pick to
join the co-op
and pay five or ten dollars a month
every month with their lot rent so that
when they get to the 300
then their membership was
in the park was okay
so it was almost like they forced
the
most the majority of these people
because they said well
if you don't join the co-op then you
have to pay 200 extra a month on rent
like i said to you before most of us are
senior citizens we live on social
security 764 50 a month for
water and sewer
and and if i can add to that when
we had this meeting and one of the board
members
motioned this was in all of these rules
and i had read everything and he said i
motioned to raise first it was supposed
to be fifty dollars i motioned to raise
it to two hundred i stood up and i said
carl that's outrageous you can't do that
to people
somebody on the board seconded and that
was it so this bill is this bill is
amazing
if you
can i think i'm still confused okay what
is yes
do you
do you own anything i mean do you own
your lot
no do you own anything we own at the
homes that we live in but if you look at
brock's website right
they say we're home we are we are
landowners
so wow what is some i mean so let's
let's get a step back and i was going to
let tara introduce this but let's be
sure everybody understands a little bit
going back
at one point in time we have
uh i think it was jensen company was a
big was a big uh owner of manufactured
housing parks
and the issue was that they could sell
that park out you know the end to
anybody they want
the issue that i thought was a little
disconcerting was the vast majority of
these homeowners
do not have a lease
so they actually have no control over
rent increases so a park could be sold
to somebody else who could triple triple
the rent okay
so uh in the wisdom of the legislature
we decided to uh create the community
loan fund association to allow the parks
to be purchased
by
the homeowners
now i can say in my one town we have one
park it was already bought before i
moved to ranch so so i i didn't have you
know this is so to me that seemed
perfect sense the problem is the devil's
in the details of when the legislation
was created
that it said is well if you're going to
have this initial vote who's going to
make the vote and
i i wasn't around for when that law was
created at least i don't think so but
maybe it was i don't know it was it was
okay good
and but that in there they had this
concept of members creating them members
and you you pay a nominal fee wasn't
really stated what the fee was and it
was a little loosey-goosey but that was
the beginning effort to how do we make
this process
work to allow the park to be sold to one
of these loan funds and so what happened
was
as you could all see that that you know
the devil's in the details and then the
thing blew up because they got out of
control with the fees they got out of
control of the relationships of people
who showed up and this whole idea of the
members um and obviously that's the
reason why this legislation is here
because we just need to uh clarify and
make it a little fair a little more
common sense and more rational than what
was originally and not only that it
helps the people that live in the co-ops
too and it gives them a better insight
of what they're getting into don't you
think and my last statement here if you
if you read i i'm here on behalf of many
residents who are too afraid to appear
here today they are already facing
retaliation from our neighbors and they
are fearful that there will be more to
come because of our efforts today i
didn't really want to say that i thought
that you could read it but that's our
reality in that
and
just to mirror that louise and i have
been under constant constant retaliation
since the three of us have brought this
bill forward and
testified um it's and it's only for the
benefits yeah it's only for the benefits
yeah it's an exciting film but you're
benefiting and they're benefiting the
other people who are also going forward
right and so
there's a little egg on the face of the
of your right but
that again they should be happy because
that would get more people involved in
co-ops when they can see what they have
so to retaliate
against three people who have been
trying to help the co-ops and the people
upcoming the people now
it's just not it's not fair it's very
unfortunate you know it's just it's not
right
but again thank you thank you and thank
you senator susie
do you have a brief question
representative just another sad reminder
that no good deed goes unpunished there
you go
amen
thank you very much
representative i will be really quick i
just want to thank you for your bravery
in coming here but i also want to say
that i'm distraught to find out that i'm
elderly at age 67. so thank you for that
well we're not
do we look good no
my seven year my seven-year-old
granddaughter thinks i'm a dinosaur well
that's like my three-year-old grandson
said you can't do that grammy because
you're going to die next week
thank you very much ladies okay the
chair will call on tara reardon from the
new hampshire community loan fund
good morning afternoon tara
good afternoon chairman hunt and members
of the commerce committee and i i saw
chairman hunt delighting in making me at
this point in the testimony because he
knew i would have just a little as
senator susie said cleaning up to do
fact-wise
so let me do my planned testimony first
and then go back to some of the
questions that were just asked and
answered
i work for the new hampshire community
loan fund which is a community
development finance authority it is a
federally created financial institution
there's about a thousand of them
nationwide but the community loan fund
is one of the oldest and the best known
we're a new hampshire non-profit
organization not associated with the
state and our service footprint is new
hampshire
our mission is to assist people who
don't have access to capital nobody will
lend them money is that what that
translates to to more fully participate
in new hampshire's economy we do that by
taking in local investments from new
hampshire people we pay them a return on
an investment and we lend it out to
other people who otherwise wouldn't be
participating
so 37 years ago the new hampshire
community loan fund started with a
meredith manufactured housing park that
was going to close because the mom and
pop owners were entering a nursing home
and the the people were going to lose
their their land to redevelopment there
were 17 homes they went to every bank
they couldn't get a loan from any place
but they did meet a student who
connected them to the community loan
fund and the sisters of mercy made the
community loan fund its very first
investment so the community loan fund in
fact could help out meredith village
cooperative
a successful co-op
cooperative to this day those same homes
still sitting in the same place and the
and the son of one of them who we stay
in touch with tells us what a difference
it made in his life
um
so manufactured homes are a great home
ownership opportunity for even low and
moderate income people they're
affordable
that's the good news and 75 percent of
the people populations that we work with
fit the low and moderate income criteria
the bad news is when you own your home
and it's on rented land there's some
instability there you always face the
possibility that the land can be bought
by somebody else it may be another
investor who's going to run it as a
manufacturing housing park it may be
somebody who's going to clear that land
because it's a nice flat site that they
can develop
and in fact sometimes there's closure
and the land isn't even developed
or it can be a lot increased so high
that you can't afford to live there
anymore and you don't move these homes
you walk away from these homes if you
can't sell them
so representative de palmer i wish he
was here has the most famous of those
examples in the state of new hampshire
where it happened in littleton in a
community called willowdale which had a
really sad uh out turn so a smart common
sense solution for that is for the
residents to come together form a
cooperative and buy the land themselves
and that's what the community loan fund
does and we've done it 142 times in the
state of new hampshire it is an
incredible and and all are still
successful
we've not only lent them the money to do
that but we provided on average 20 000
hours of technical assistance a year to
help people run their community
as introduced sb 210 would have almost
eliminated this program we would have
closed one of those
communities in the last two years that i
went back and looked at that part and
all of the uh talk that you're hearing
about voting and voting thresholds and
how many people were at the meeting was
eliminated in this bill when in fact
senator susie and senator bradley red
drafted the amendment not an issue
anymore but i'll clear up a little bit
of that in a minute
so the most successful new hampshire
created homegrown local solution to an
affordable housing crisis sounds like
something that we probably ought to be
preserving
not only has new hampshire done this
with 142 co-ops but the movement has
taken off across the united states
there's a hundred and fifty more of
these communities in uh 20 other states
so we worked with senator bradley and
senator susie and came up with this
amendment uh and it brought up some
really good discussion and some really
good agreements uh resulted from that
the most onerous as i said the voting
threshold was taken out that we're
thankful for that absentee ballots are a
great idea we know that not everybody
can get out of their house they have
challenges sometimes to getting out to
voting and cooperative
a low dollar joining fee is a great idea
and the small differential for rent for
members non-members 200 dollars we find
that offensive that is nothing we have
anything to do with in fact the
residents vote for that so
you would hope that neighbors would help
out neighbors and be thoughtful of that
and that didn't happen we have no other
community that has a two hundred dollar
rent differential in the state of new
hampshire i am proud to say
but it has also brought up conversations
at the new hampshire community loan fund
us as a lender
going forward will flag those kinds of
things we have the choice to fund those
groups and decide whether or not that's
a group that we want to fund and in fact
the answer may be no in some of those
situations where
neighbors don't have their neighbor's
best interests in mind
um so sp 210 adds it to law and it adds
it to 205a
i think it's probably suited better in
301a which is actually the consumer
cooperative statute we needed to get to
an agreement
we did
i mentioned we are thinking about that
in our lending criteria having a lot of
conversation about that and the other
part of the bill that changed was you
notice that the park owners association
gets a notice of
the residents buying these communities
or that there's a community available to
purchase we ask that the terms of that
deal be excluded from the statute you
can find out that the park is being sold
but we don't want other park owners
finding out what the terms of the deal
is that's
that is just not something that we're in
favor of um in our book a little a
little a little invasive for our
especially an unrelated party that they
have nothing to do with um there was a
companion bill 324 that you'll hear next
week it set up a dispute resolution
which
in the event there was a dispute
resolution in each one of these
communities they could probably take
care of that themselves i don't know
what's going to happen to sb 324 but
we're committed at the community loan
fund to look at the template bylaws we
provide and make sure that that can be
happening on the ground level in each
one of these
communities
i also want to offer i would be glad all
of you probably have a resident owned
community with 142 of them in your
community someplace i would love to have
a conversation to tell you what's in
your district we do business and child
care lending to the community loan fund
is a really great resource for the state
of new hampshire we want to make sure
people not only know about it but can
take advantage
i want to just go back to a couple of
the things that were said in response to
questions and maybe not not asked of the
person that could best respond to those
um
so the voting threshold isn't in the
bill anymore um bearview cooperative i
went back and looked after our senate
hearing there were actually 100 members
when they made their final vote when
they knew what their mortgage was going
to be what their lot rent would increase
to and all of that
as you know because you're all elected
officials i'm an elected official if you
can get you know 50 percent of people to
show up for me that's pretty amazing
nowadays but we do go through that pro
former line by line and i will say
bearview had very very high rent and
they had a fannie mae mortgage that has
to be defeased which i won't tell you
about it's just it adds a million
dollars
to the sales price that
complicated that they do have four
mortgages on the property bankprov an
institutional lender who sees these as
great
opportunities
where a second mortgage holder on their
community were also a third mortgage
holder they needed more money than they
had to close in those mortgages and we
gave them a zero percent loan because we
didn't want them to raise their rent
more than five dollars at the time we
look at these transactions very very
carefully and you'll hear from elliot
berry we are very very conscious about
what the what the acceptable market rate
rent is in that area and not to go above
that because when we do that it makes it
really hard for them to sell a home
there's other choices and they won't be
able to sell their home
if in fact that happens um
and the pro forma we do a pro forma
obviously as all lenders do for all of
those transactions um i i also just want
to point out um that um
nobody paid two or three hundred dollars
to vote when you when you want to buy a
piece of property that costs 18 million
dollars banks don't just say okay those
five guys over there can have the loan
you have to form a business entity the
business entity that we help people form
as a consumer cooperative
the the statute requires that there be
some kind of joining fee for you to join
that cooperative we in most cases make
it five bucks that's what people can
afford their membership fee may in fact
be 300 again the residents decide that
themselves we don't we don't do that and
they don't pay that 300 unless they buy
the community we're not going to have
somebody pay 300 bucks up front to join
a cooperative if in fact they never buy
the community it's unaffordable so when
they buy the community they then can pay
it at the rate of five dollars a month
with their rent and if it takes them you
know six years to pay it off then that's
what happens new people coming in just
like a condo or any other conveyance you
pay your membership fee as part of your
closing costs
when you come in so i hope that clears
things up
there are some instances when neighbors
make bad decisions for their that
include their other neighbors we are not
in favor of that we uh are instituting
practices to keep that from happening um
in the future and i would be more than
happy to answer questions or clarify
anything else that you've heard that
really feels
ugly
representative greeson
thank you ms chairman thank you for your
testimony and thank you for clarifying a
lot of that
information
of the 142 communities in the state
um
how many of these communities have paid
off their mortgage and they own it free
and clear what was the average amount of
time taken to pay off those loans
because i this may just be an
exceptionally
bad deal or something because i don't
see how bear creek pays off in under a
hundred years
um i i can't tell you the exact number
of um co-ops that um have paid off their
mortgage but i can tell you they have a
party when it happens and they get very
very excited
there is a co-op in winchester new
hampshire who has not raised its rent
does not have a mortgage has not raised
its lot rent in 20 years it's still 240
dollars and that's the beauty of a
not-for-profit consumer cooperative so
as to the
21 million dollars the prices for
manufactured housing parks are becoming
extreme because they are such a hot
investment for private equity money
coming from outside the state of new
hampshire and it's wild we do
a 10-year mortgage with a 40-year
amortization and refinance that at 10
years as do the lenders
td bank bank of new hampshire bank prob
everybody that's in the first place
position because lenders aren't going to
commit to that interest rate more than
10 years we will refinance it at that
time and they'll have another 40-year
amortization but our explanation to the
residents is you want to pay your home
off because you're dying to retire
someday on the fixed incomes that that
you have the cooperative we don't want a
higher rent right now so somebody gets
to live cheap in 50 years this is a
forever perpetual corporation and it
makes sense for us to do it that way
thank you thank you very much and just
just for reference i i crunched the
numbers on 10 if they if it was 10 years
just paid it off in 10 years it's
583.33
dollars per month just to pay off the
principal
per household in that park so that's
just not doable we we have a we have a
community uh right now in rochester that
we just started working with this week
it has 491 homes in the community their
rent is over 500
and the purchase price for the community
is 54 million dollars it's the same
owner as they had the same park owner
that they have who's a
guy out of canada
the lot rent alone in that
community
brings in over 250 000 a month so when
we talk about debt service we look at
that so at the income that's coming in
right now there's three million dollars
available to you know mow the lawns pay
the property manager and um and pay the
debt service so
the lot rents completely dictate what
what size debt service could be serviced
yeah
representative abel
yes thank you thank you for
explaining things but i have to be
honest and say
that i understand this less now than i
did when i read this
and i i would like to ask sort of a
general question
i
don't feel
ever that i can vote for a bill if i
don't understand it i do not understand
this bill
and if we were having our executive
session now i would certainly vote
against the bill
i wonder how you would respond to that
uh
sir i i served on this committee for
seven terms we had a lot of bills that
covered a lot of
subject matter that was very hard to be
an expert in each one of those i respect
what you have to say
and i will say i tried to note in my
testimony some of the red flag issues
that we've seen
we are going to fix uh as a lender and
and not be a lender if there's a 200
rent differential so although
this bill might not survive the point
i'm making is a lot of the issues that
we have seen in the communities
we can probably handle as a lender to
that community by prohibiting those
practices
and uh i know that i'm as a chairman i'm
not supposed to say this but
uh rich i just hope you paid attention
to who is in support of the bill
and who is showing support
i'm in support
with a little bit of concerns
about some of the disclosure but pay
attention to the people who are in
support of the bill
and with that
well thank you very much for your
testimony thank you mr chairman
and i have one card left eliot berry
new hampshire legal assistance who
everyone knows because i think i see you
on television ward
and i see the governor on television
can you hold on a second and turn your
microphone on uh pretty confident just
hold just that pattern let's take a
breath
we
our computer crashed so
how are we doing now okay uh well we'll
tell you we'll say it's dragon speak so
we have to wait till it loads
because we want to remember every word
you save
each one's a gem
okay
uh again for the record my name is
elliot berry i'm the director of housing
justice at new hampshire legal
assistance where i've been a practicing
attorney for over 40 years i'm even
older than john i think
i have an interesting
viewpoint about all this i should say
from the start that i'm one of the
founders
of the new hampshire community loan fund
i also was one of the drafters and
lobbyists behind the the
uh rsa 205 section was at 17 through 22
which started this co-op movement
and
but interestingly enough
right now today
most of my involvement comes
from
from defending tenants who are getting
evicted from parks including co-op parks
so i'm not going to sit here and tell
you this is like the greatest thing that
has ever happened
to owners of manufactured housing
however
what makes me so happy about this uh
amendment
is that it closes one of the biggest
problems that i have seen and that is
that giant rent differential be often
200 off the charts and this that their
park is the only one i've ever seen it
but i really thank the folks from bear
but i used to be bear brook i forget
their view
they've done a great service by you know
creating momentum to to really make it
as
affordable as it possibly can be
and
and it is terrific if i could just give
you a little bit of background the
reason that the current law is in effect
that gives the tenants notice and an
opportunity to purchase it came out of
basically a disaster in milford where an
owner was selling the park and the new
owner was going to close it
and there were 55 people there who were
absolutely it was you know like a
tornado would come and wipe out the
whole community
so that created momentum to create a
situation where to the maximum possible
extent
people who own their homes in a
manufactured housing park
never had to worry about getting having
their park closed and getting displaced
by that or by having a series of
investor owners purchase and sell
purchase and sell purchase and sell
until yeah and the price just keeps
skyrocketing which is in fact still
happening in the private market today
that's a benefit that no matter what the
chinks are what the problems are in
certain co-ops that benefit is i think
it so outweighs any of those problems
that
in that i think especially with the
improvements that have
that this bill is making
is just going to
to provide the maximum amount of
protection that manufactured housing
park owners will have
there's still going to be plenty of
cases though the way the prices are
going crazy on manufactured housing
parks they're going to be kept places at
times when the tenants even with the
even with the funding from the community
loan fund and bankers who have
understood their value but there's going
to be times we're just not going to be
able to do it but at least the law
that we currently have
will give gives the the tenants a
fighting chance for the homeowners a
fighting chance and with the changes
we've made uh it'll enable them to keep
the rents as low as possible
so with that i just
joined the lovin and ask you all to
support the image
we've known each other a long time enjoy
this and i i can't
let you go without saying this this is
or would you believe okay so you don't
have to respond but i still go back to
this problem never would have occurred
if the own homeowners
had a lease
i'm not allowed to say okay you're
allowed to respond
like the state of connecticut has that
law
and i always said that would have solved
a lot of problems if we had passed that
law
thanks
good to see you all good seeing you all
right i have no more cards uh the blue
sheets
uh we had eight support two opposed
and
the sign in sheet we have john murphy uh
himself in support and tom derussa from
housing action new hampshire also in
support and without a close the public
hearing
believe in me the senate
[Music]
thank you
how many
is
um
i do think
that there is an opportunity
so here's who makes it
and you haven't come back
not yet
where i don't have space and it should
be something
i could do
right
so
i can clearly agree on
no problem chairman you are not the only
one running behind today
[Laughter]
all right um good afternoon everyone
thanks for having me for the record i am
senator rebecca perkins quoca
representing senate district 21 which is
the city of portsmouth
and the towns of durham newmarket
newfields newington madbury and lee
i am here to introduce sb212 relative to
liquor manufacturers
sb 212 is a request that comes from the
new hampshire craft brewers association
and i personally have been working with
a member of my district out of flag hill
winery in lee
the intent of this bill is essentially
to allow craft brewers of liquor to
serve cocktails at their tasting rooms
up to two cocktails when food is
available
it will allow craft brewers to it will
also allow craft brewers to sell their
product at farmers markets under
different limitations that are now more
relevant there was a previous limitation
which excluded had the practical effect
of excluding almost all liquor
manufacturers from such markets
we all saw how businesses suffered
during the closures and limitations of
the coven 19 pandemic and this bill
which i affectionately call the new
hampshire craft cocktail support act
it's just another tool in the toolbox to
aid a small business industry in their
recovery
you know the intent here is is to allow
for distillers essentially to showcase
their product in a different way um i i
wouldn't
presume to
comment on anyone's habits here in the
room but i know
many like to enjoy cocktails as opposed
to drinking their liquor
straighter plane and so the ability here
for our small businesses to make sure
that
their product can kind of be shown in
its diversity or in different
applications is a way
that these small businesses can
continue to to grow
you know their customer base and their
business provide jobs in our state um
you know and continue to be a part of
our economy
in um in center commerce we
amended sb 212 to address the concerns
of the liquor commission um
making sure that
uh
we reduced the amount of liquor that was
able to be served by a half ounce
and we wanted to accommodate them
because it has been a very collaborative
process
once amended sb212 passed center
commerce unanimously and it passed the
full senate on the consent calendar so
um i will leave it at that and i am
happy to answer any questions that i'm
able
okay
representative johnson
just out of curiosity didn't part of
this
didn't we already passed something like
already
so wouldn't this part of it be a
redundant bill
as far as the uh liquor manufacturing
and farmers markets
yes so well so that's why i'm asking
because i thought we already passed it
out of here last session might be more
relevant for mr moore
exactly um so i'm going to defer
representative to let the gentleman
behind me answer that in more detail but
but my understanding is that you did
pass something similar but that what
we're proposing today would um would
allow more participation in the farmers
markets
it's an ad it's an adjunct bill
well mr mr chair i understand your
question because i was actually about to
ask the same thing we had another
question first okay
thank you mr chair i was just confused
about one thing um when you can have it
says you can have two cocktails
um with two ounces of liquor each are
those could those be provided free
it wasn't clear to me because it says
they could be for you know before you
could pay a fee or free is that the same
with the two cocktails with the two
ounces each
um the intent is
for them to be available as part of um
a paid tasting but i'm also going to
defer your question to the gentleman
behind me because i think that
it's an option to be offered free or not
but i don't want to mistake so okay i'm
probably in the minority would you
believe but i would be smashed if i had
two cocktails with two ounces each fair
enough
thank you for your would you believe
it
representative greeson thank you
mr chairman and thank you senator for
this i think the the
my
recollection of a similar nature and we
we can always defer to someone else
later but it's around the number 839
leader cases of his products there's a
similar
uh and it wasn't 830 and what i'm
concerned about is whatever we passed
previously and this may not be the same
numbers and now we're going to end up
having a collision of of worlds here so
i if it's something you can't answer i
appreciate that i'm
certain we want to i just want to make
sure that we're not
we're not messing something up here yeah
thank you representative i do not have
the history you're looking for but i do
believe that my constituent does
thank you senator
okay uh for your testimony all right and
uh
thank you very much i would strongly
suspect there is
a peak card
for a
certain aiden moore
thank you
is there no pink card
hayden
good afternoon mr chairman
i have not provided the card uh i was
really here to answer any questions that
the committee might have
uh for the committee's benefit my name
is aiden moore i'm the legal coordinator
for the state liquor commission
and uh
mr chairman i'd like to i think the bill
that you looked at
was a bill that originally came to you
as a bill
dealing
with creating a
distiller's license for farmers
and that bill was amended and changed to
now allow
for a second tier of distilled beverage
production
the distiller's license
costs 1 692
and in an interest of bringing a tiered
approach to distilling
the committee passed a bill
that would allow
a business that produces i believe under
under
i think it's under a thousand cases
to now pay a fee of 300
so it's kind of an incubator license get
them in business and once their
production increases and goes beyond
that then the fee would be adjusted
upward
so uh
on on this particular bill sir
as the senator said uh you'll hear from
representatives of the distillers area
we were very happy to
work with them
especially on the areas of product
tasting
and to
ask them to consider changing
the earlier bill to an ounce and a half
for which really represents a standard
pour
if you will for spirits
and to have some uniformity in the
pouring process
if you will
the
provision that has
is being changed here in part two
lines
excuse me lines six and seven
this was brought to you
last uh maybe two years ago
as a method of product allowing
distillers to get into the farmers
market wine manufacturers can do it
beverage manufacturers can do it and
this was to allow distillers
to
keep it a
method of providing for the craft
distiller to be able to get into the
marketplace
the senate agreed to amend a bill to
identify businesses
that produced less than ten thousand
bottles as a threshold of eligibility
and i think you'll hear from the
industry behind me
where some of their members now have
exceeded that or are exceeding it which
is now taking them away from the farmers
market opportunities and they're looking
to provide a new formula
that would allow their members to
continue to participate in a farmer's
market
so with that i'd be happy to take any
questions you might have sir our
committee members
seeing
uh you mr chair thank you for taking my
question
so um
you're
in support of the bill or you're just
here to answer questions and we're here
to answer questions
and so if this
bill did pass then you would work with
the distilleries too
we do
their president uh brian ferguson is uh
we have a work a great working
relationship with that organization and
he is a fine representative of that
industry great thanks
thank you
representative johnson
thank you for taking my question um kind
of
back to what representative greeson was
saying
can we make sure that we're not in
conflict with some of the
other bills that we passed last session
especially with this 890 leader case i
don't want to see us a conflict and then
them get in trouble and we're battling
back and forth i'd like to make sure
we're all on the same page
agreed representative
what we're trying to certainly do with
this
is that um
the figure that they're proposing this
this
839 liter cases um would allow them if
they're having a 12 bottle case 750
milliliters would be roughly 9 960
bottles so their members could sell at
farmers market up to that quantity
um
and
if they sold less obviously they could
do that but they couldn't sell more than
that
that is this this provision is
distinguished from the earlier bill
because that
is a bill dealing with production only
so
if you decided you wanted to open a
distillery
and you said you know gee i understand
it's six you know sixteen hundred
dollars to open one i i don't have that
kind of start-up money then the bill you
passed said
well if you make less than a thousand
cases
then
your fee will not be 1600 it'll be 300.
by getting that license you would still
be eligible to participate in the
farmers markets you're just a
you're just a distiller that produces
less than some others so it really
offers
an opportunity for new businesses to get
in
it certainly would because they are a
distiller they would still be able to
get into the farmers market
business
but they would need to adhere to the
quantity limits that are part of this
amendment
no questions thank you
thank you mr chairman
okay
mr brian ferguson
welcome mr ferguson long time no see
thank you yeah it's been a long time how
is everyone
good yeah lively
[Laughter]
um my name is brian ferguson i am the
president of the new hampshire craft
spirits organization i'm here on their
behalf today
um
i uh
basically be would be repeating
essentially what uh senator uh rebecca
perkins cuoco said
um
so i'm not gonna read everything i had
written because it's just about the
exact same thing as that uh the one
thing i would bring up is you had uh
representative burroughs i believe you
had brought up um it being two ounces we
had reduced that from two ounces to to
one and a half ounces uh in conjunction
with a uh working relation our working
relationship with the national
commission
um
i'm willing to uh to take any uh take
any questions
we're obviously in support of the bill
and and think it would bring a
a lot to the new hampshire craft spirits
producers
and a lot to this data would give us an
opportunity to produce more revenue
therefore produce more more tax revenue
okay see no questions
thank
you mr ferguson thank you everybody
would you believe that you can visit mr
ferguson at flag hill
i have from time to time
thank you
okay uh
christopher burke from cathedral ledge
distillery
which i have not had the opportunity to
visit yet
thank you mr chairman you're certainly
always welcome to come visit uh and
thank you the rest of the committee i'll
be brief obviously the day's wearing on
i wanted really just to focus on
emphasizing the importance of gaining
access to the farmers markets
we happen to be a certified organic
distillery and so the opportunity to get
out and meet fellow granite staters that
value local organic
products is uh very important to us
we also think that what we've been told
from the organizers of the farmers
markets reef contact is that having a
diversity of products
at their markets
strengthens the marketplace for the
already existing providers
more more customers are interested and
more foot traffic benefits all
to address that that bottle number it
really was just standardizing the the
units um
there's a there's a
there's a trend at the federal level
to allow
a variety of sizes of bottles and so the
proliferation of bottle sizes is only
going to get worse
it comes from people who sell into
different countries a lot of metric
friendly sizes but you're going to see
all kinds of different bottle sizes and
so by by running laws as nine liter
equivalents then you don't have to worry
about people gaming the rules by
offering really big or really small
bottles and so that's that's what that
was
an attempt to be
the same amount of alcohol uh just in a
unit that you don't have to worry about
the individual bottles
so
if you have any questions i'm happy to
answer them otherwise i won't take more
of your time
thank you mr chair um
farmer's markets are you involved in a
farmer's market
no well probably not
yeah so we went uh we went to our local
farmers market twice last fall
before it was realized that we crossed
the 10 000 bottle
produced
threshold so the original legislation
passed last year
it it limited your ability to go to the
market based on what you produce not
based on what you sell
which once you produce it the next thing
you want to do is sell it so it kind of
put us in an awkward situation
certainly the two times we went we were
very well received
by both customers and fellow vendors
and uh just a follow-up when you go to
uh farmers market markets um i guess it
probably depends on the farmers markets
but are there
a few distilleries that are represented
is that commonplace well so we went as
soon as the law was passed um and so we
were the only ones because the law was
literally days old um
i i don't i don't know how many will
participate going forward
so that's yet to be seen i i can tell
you though that in other states
especially vermont is kind of a poster
child
the farmer's market is the primary way
to market for most craft distillers
they sell far more at farmers markets
than they do in their own tasting rooms
or through the agency stores
so it's it's a very important and
well-developed model to
introduce your products
to consumers um
we pay taxes on any sales at farmers
markets but hopefully the point is that
they will like the products and then go
to their new hampshire state uh wine and
spirits outlet and purchase more
and uh one more question here should we
follow up the um
maine new hampshire expo
yeah are distilleries represented there
so
can they be i i don't know if they can
be my understanding is that they
probably cannot because we probably
don't have the license
um yeah i was actually thinking that if
this passes and it would be a good
follow-up question
uh to see whether or not we'd be
allowed to participate in the future i
think for this year that's not going to
happen
right that's a great question thanks
well seeing no more questions thank you
thank you all for your time
okay i have one final card
uh for gregory
beak
beak meech mech
okay
cold garden spirits
thank you chairman
thank you committee members my name is
gregory me uh cold garden spirits in
canterbury new hampshire uh we're a farm
distillery we grow a lot of the product
that we turn into spirits but we also
purchase from our local farmers and
orchards
i thought it would be
helpful for you to know
a real real world experience that i had
just the other day
that reflects
what
the results of your work here supporting
us as the new hampshire craft spirits
organization
i drove over to moral farm dairy in
penacook
and i bought 600 pounds of barley and
no 600 pounds of rye and 300 pounds of
barley
five years ago moral farm dairy was not
growing grain for the spirits or the
beer trade
about five years ago when we founded the
craft spirits organization
we
made an effort to
encourage our members to purchase
locally if they could possibly find a
way to do so
uh this is personal for me i grew up on
a dairy farm that went out of business
when i was 10 years old
moral farm dairy three years ago put in
about an eighteen
hundred pound uh eighteen hundred bushel
elevator for storing grain
last year they put in two
5 000 bushel grain elevators
this year they're putting in more than
twice that
most of this is for the beer trade and
they're sending it to
malting houses in massachusetts and in
maine to be malted
and then ship back into state for our
local brewers who want to feature local
product
so
your support
of us
goes out to
our small family farms here in the state
and it makes me feel great
so thank you very much for your time
thank you very much for your testimony
just yes representative i knew it was a
question yes there would you believe i
have visited
his distillery and it's right outside
canterbury village and it's a great
visit
we really enjoyed
the product
thank you thank you thank you
representative uh to my fellow
representatives also would you believe
i've been involved with you can you can
go back i've been involved with the beer
the wine
the distilled spirits and farmers
markets ever since the beginning
and i've seen this grow
i was on the
alcohol tourism commission
with brian
and a lot of what's going on now is some
of the outcomes that we were talking
about
two and three years ago but there was
never a final report issued
but these guys are taking the bull by
the horns and doing this
and uh i just thought he would share
that with you
i know you remember it rich
you remember yeah field trip oh
and yes we're always open to being
invited to go on field trips
okay
uh uh representative abel yeah this this
is just an informal question i'm just
curious um how much
of what you've produced
is sold in new hampshire and how much
has been exported outside of new
hampshire just just uh
just curious
okay thank you everyone i believe
there's no more questions
we're done
you